Ok. Sekunde, was hat Teams wieder mit meinem Mikrofon gemacht?
Lul. Ne, wieso? Stimmt doch alles.
Mittlerweile bin ich schon so paranoid, was das angeht. Teams muss rumgestellt haben im Mikrofon.
Hat's auch meistens.
Ist ja, kommt ja nicht von ungefähr. Ist halt die Erfahrung gezeigt, Teams ändert immer die Mikrofonsettings.
Und ich hab bis heute nicht kapiert, wie man das Teams abgewöhnen kann.
Falls es überhaupt geht.
Das gehört wahrscheinlich zur authentischen Teams-Experience, dass das Mikrofonsettings verkackt.
Eine extra VM für Teams. Ja, da musst du dann aber das Mikrofon durchpasstruhen irgendwie.
Das ist auch nicht so sinnvoll.
So. Also.
Ja, es geht. Also du kannst Sounds relativ gut weiterreichen in VMware, aber das laggt teilweise.
Also du hast bei, gerade bei Output, bei Input weiß ich's nicht.
Also gerade bei Output hast du durchaus gerne mal so eine Highlight.
Halbe Sekunde Verzögerung, was ein bisschen nervig ist.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das auch noch in Kombination mit Puls-Audio noch mal beschissener ist.
Dass es dann irgendwie bei einer Sekunde liegt.
Man kann die Buffer-Size in den VM-Settings ein bisschen verringern.
Da muss man aber in das Text-File.
Dafür hast du dann teilweise geruckelt.
Richtig pünktlich auf die Minute.
Ja, Leute, soll ich sagen, das war keine Absicht.
Wirklich keine Absicht.
Ich sitz schon seit so irgendwie kurz nach 8 hier vorm Rechner.
Und hab ein paar Sachen rumgeklickt.
Und hab ich gedacht, so, jetzt ist es soweit.
Und ich hab nicht auf die Uhr geguckt.
Das war wirklich Zufall, dass es pünktlich um 9 war.
Ja, Audio unter Linux ist teilweise echt ein bisschen Painschamp.
Ich hab übrigens ein ziemlich gutes Video letztens gesehen, wo einer sich drüber ausgelassen hat.
Über Windows, Linux, Mac aus Entwicklersicht.
Ich find, das war ziemlich gut auf den Punkt gebracht.
Auch wenn ich...
Nicht alles so sehe, aber im Großen und Ganzen muss ich sagen, dass das trifft es ganz gut.
Aber was war das?
Mal kurz gucken, YouTube.
Wie heißen die irgendwie so, ne?
Genau, das Video war wirklich nicht schlecht.
Jetzt gucken wir uns vielleicht irgendwann...
Hier, das einzig wahre Betriebssystem zum Programmieren.
Das da, nicht jetzt.
Aber das Video fand ich wirklich gute Zusammenfassung.
Vielleicht soll ich das nicht hier aufmachen, sondern im YouTube-Video-Guck-Tab.
Weil ansonsten...
Ups, ich hab das Video Pause gedrückt.
WTF?
Microsoft.
Oder, in dem Fall eher Google.
WTF ist das?
Ah.
Leute, wisst ihr, was mir aufgefallen ist in YouTube-Sumnails?
Äh, ich...
In dem Moment sieht man was.
Ähm, Kreise, beziehungsweise Kreise weniger, Pfeile sind wieder im Kommen.
Guckt mal hier unten auch.
Pfeile sind gerade wieder im Trend.
Ist mir in den letzten paar Wochen aufgefallen.
Es gibt immer mehr Sumnails, die wieder dieses Oldschool-Pfeil-Dings verwenden.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass es mittlerweile gerne so gemacht wird.
So was weiß ich...
Ähm...
Noob-Pro.
Und dann hast du hier in der Mitte das Bild geteilt und dann links ein Bild von einem Noob und rechts ein Pfeil auf einem Pro oder sowas.
Das ist zur Zeit echt wieder im Kommen.
Müsst ihr euch...
Guckt hier!
Ja?
Das...
Dieses gesplitterte Bild und dann mit dem Pfeil.
Das ist...
Das ist aktuell echt im Trend wieder.
Äh...
Warte mal.
Sound-Control-Panel.
Ach ne.
Moment.
In Settings oder im alten Control-Panel?
Oder wo?
Oder hier?
Open Sound Settings?
Da?
Hier?
Man weiß ja unter Windows nie.
Altes.
Okay.
Das ist natürlich geil, dass es mit etwas Altes funktioniert.
Software und Sound.
Sound.
Äh.
Ja.
Naja.
Der Mikrofonausschlag hier und hier deckt sich, sagen wir mal...
Nicht wirklich, aber okay.
Hier.
So.
Und was jetzt?
Was?
Advanced.
Warte mal.
Mikrofon.
Recording.
Advanced.
Ja, ne.
In dem Moment.
Das funktioniert.
Aber dann hast du...
Du hast so andere Probleme.
Das hatte ich...
Ich bilde mir ein, das habe ich schon mal ausprobiert.
Und da gab es irgendwelche anderen Probleme.
Ach so.
Ich habe den Haken übrigens entfernt.
Aber das ändert...
Das juckt Teams trotzdem nicht daran, meine Mikrofon-Lautstärke lauter und leiser zu stellen.
Ludl.
Unter Linux macht er ja gut.
Unter Linux verstellt nichts ungefragt einfach deine Sound-Settings.
Unter Windows schon.
Das macht nicht nur Teams.
Aber Teams, weil ich es halt öfters verwenden muss, ist das, was mich am meisten nervt.
Okay, McDonalds-Lunch in...
Ne, das gucken wir uns nicht.
Weil das ist nicht...
Also, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch aussieht.
Ich habe aber die letzten fünf Jahre, glaube ich, kein McDonalds mehr gegessen.
Und ich habe auch nicht mehr so das Verlangen danach.
Man muss nicht...
Also, ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich McDonalds irgendwie super eklig finde oder so.
Sagen ja Leute so nach dem Motto, kann man da nicht essen.
Doch, da kann man schon essen.
Das schmeckt auch irgendwo essbar.
Ja, also, das ist nicht so, dass man sagen muss, das kann man, kriegt man nicht runter.
Aber ich habe da überhaupt keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Früher war ich da richtig scharf drauf.
Und das hat nichts damit zu tun, dass ich in letzter Zeit so viel abgenommen habe.
Ich habe schon, als ich noch pepo-fettiger war, habe ich schon keinen McDonalds mehr gefuttert.
Ja, weit...
McDonalds darf nicht gut sein.
McDonalds, also, das Ziel von McDonalds ist ja nicht, dass es gut ist.
Die tun zwar in der Werbung immer so.
Jetzt wäre das, oh, McDonalds.
Ne, das Ziel von McDonalds ist quasi das, was Mainstream-Musik oder Mobile-Games auch haben.
Du sollst nicht irgendwie Leute begeistern.
Du sollst möglichst wenig Leute abschrecken.
Also, du sollst möglichst wenig Leute es eklig finden lassen.
Also, wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Es ist wahrscheinlich für McDonalds besser, als dass ein paar Leute sagen, das ist richtig gut.
Es ist besser, wenn die meisten Leute sagen, ja, das kann man essen.
Also, wenn es für 95% der Leute okay ist, ist es besser, als wenn es die Hälfte der Leute supergeil finden und die anderen nicht mag.
Also, es funktioniert...
Das darf gar nicht besser sein, glaube ich.
Ich finde es ja auch immer überraschend, dass bei McDonalds Chicken Nuggets oder so, das da drauf steht, mit echtem Hähnchenfleisch.
Und da denke ich mir immer so, wie?
Gibt es die Option auch nicht mit echtem...
Hähnchenfleisch?
Mit Fake veganische Chicken Nuggets oder so?
Mit veganer Burger ist ja einfach nur, um die Veganer zu jibäden.
Ich weiß eh nicht, warum man als Veganer zu McDonalds gehen will.
Ich will ja schon so nicht zu McDonalds gehen.
I bought a portable Sega Dreamcast from AliExpress.
Guck, schon wieder Pfeil.
Leute, ich sag euch, dieser rote Pfeil und am besten auch mit gesplittet.
Das ist zur Zeit wieder im Trend.
Ich frag mich halt so, würde ohne den roten Pfeil niemand checken, dass er dieses Gerät hier meint?
Aber man muss halt sagen, mit dem roten Pfeil, es sieht halt einfacher klickbar aus.
Das stimmt schon.
Also, nicht...
Der macht das legit einfach auf und an.
Made in China.
Pog.
Das spricht ja schon für die immense Qualität wahrscheinlich.
Hat jemand von euch...
Hat jemand von euch in letzter Zeit was bei AliExpress bestellt?
Ich mach ja so ein bisschen einen Bogen um AliExpress.
In letzter Zeit.
Seitdem die Schiffe nicht mehr nach Shanghai rein und raus kommen.
Weiß gar nicht, ob das noch so ist.
Weiß nicht, wie die...
Wie sind da eigentlich so die Lieferzeiten gerade bei...
Wie sind da eigentlich so die Lieferzeiten bei AliExpress gerade?
Wartet mal kurz.
Muss mal kurz checken.
Damenbekleidung.
Ja.
Genau, ich wollte...
Was?
Message-Pistole?
Ach, Massage-Pistole.
Was die da einmal suchen.
So.
Also, ich wollte schon immer irgend so ein Weep...
So ein Weep-iPhone-Phone haben.
So.
Und versandt...
Bis 24...
Ne, ein Monat.
Das ist normal.
Das war früher bei AliExpress auch schon, je nachdem wie du bestellt hast.
Safer Shipping und Standard Shipping.
Ja, einen Monat.
Allerdings gab es halt oftmals bei AliExpress auch noch billiger.
Also...
Äh, nicht billiger.
Was labere ich denn?
Schneller.
Also, du konntest bei AliExpress quasi 5, 6 verschiedene Versandvarianten früher auswählen.
Wovon manche unsinnig teuer waren.
80 Euro.
80...
80 Euro Versand oder so.
Aber du konntest teilweise sowas wie EU-Priority-Line oder EU-Express-Shipping oder sowas machen.
Und dann kam das innerhalb von einer Woche an.
Oder du hattest sogar die Möglichkeit, das aus dem EU-Warenlager zu bestellen.
Das war noch besser.
Ja, genau.
Ja.
Hevigen Dank für den Sub.
28 Monate.
Massive.
Leute, ich muss unbedingt mal das Designer-Grill fragen, ob wir weitere Sub-Kekse bekommen können.
Weil den Gold-Keks mit Kette, den haben ja die meisten, die jetzt schon länger dabei sind, schon.
Das muss noch ein bisschen upgraded werden.
Ja, Gold-Kette mit...
Ja, mir fällt gar nichts ein.
Aber dafür hat man ja Creative-Fivehead-Designer.
Den, was einfällt.
Ich kann jetzt ja auch nicht sagen, ich mach den Gold-Keks mit Kette hinten hin.
Weil dann beschweren sich die Leute, die den Gold-Keks mit Kette schon haben, dass sie den Gold-Keks mit Kette nicht mehr haben.
Das ist wie wenn Games sagen, so wie bei New World zum Beispiel.
Du bist quasi...
Im Endgame machst du Progression und dann sagen die beim Patch, ach nee, Progression ist jetzt schwieriger.
Du kriegst dein Item jetzt doch nicht.
So, das kann ich ja nicht machen.
Diamant-Keks haben wir schon.
Wir haben normalen Keks.
Wir haben Silber-Keks.
Wir haben Diamant-Keks.
Und wir haben Gold-Keks.
Was mit roten Pfeilen?
Ja, man könnte...
Das Problem ist, man muss...
Also, man kann dem Keks nichts auf den Kopf setzen.
Außer einen Stirnband eventuell oder so.
Aber das passt nicht wirklich.
Weil, das macht es kleiner.
Wisst ihr, wenn hier oben jetzt...
Wenn hier oben so ein Hut wäre...
Wenn hier oben ein Hut wäre, dann würde es das ganze Seitenverhältnis von dem Bild...
Von dem Bild...
Stonks-Keks.
Man könnte vielleicht noch irgendwie hier in die Gold-Kette...
Einen 100-Dollar-Schein oder einen Euro-Schein oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Müsste man sich echt überlegen, was man da machen kann.
Einen Anhänger an die Kette.
Ja, das könnte man tatsächlich machen.
Mit den...
Wisst ihr, was das Einfachste wäre?
Wenn man wirklich einfach einen Anhänger dran machen würde.
Mit den Monaten oder so.
Weil, sonst fällt mir halt nichts ein.
Sonst müsste ich mir irgendwie für jedes...
Für jede paar Monate einen neuen Keks überlegen, was schwierig ist.
Vielleicht lasse ich auch einfach komplett neue Sub-Emotes...
Also neue, neue...
Nicht Sub-Emotes, neue...
Subscription-Badges machen.
Die...
Aber die Kekse mit dem Gold...
Gold, das ist schon...
Passt schon.
Finde ich schon nicht schlecht.
Ja, Sonnenbrille ist das Einzige, was mir auch schon eingefallen ist.
Tatsächlich.
Also Sonnenbrille habe ich mir schon...
Aber das ist...
Das hat übrigens auch, glaube ich, letztens der Chat vorgeschlagen.
Das Bild, Alter.
Sonnenbrille, auf die Idee bin ich auch schon gekommen.
Ansonsten fällt mir...
Mir da nicht mehr allzu viel ein.
Das wird man hier auch halbwegs drauf erkennen.
Naja.
Keine Ahnung, das kann ich wieder zumachen.
Übrigens, Leute, wisst ihr, was wir machen müssen in einem der Streams in nächster Zeit?
Wir müssen Python lernen.
Python.
Was heißt lernen?
Ich kann das ja halbwegs.
Brauchbar.
So.
Wenn es mal sein muss.
Aber nicht wirklich gut.
Und...
Mir ist aufgefallen in letzter Zeit, dass ich öfters mal irgendwelchen kleinen Skript-Kram habe,
der...
Zu nervig, lange in Bash ist.
Und zu ätzend in Bash ist.
Und...
Wo es sich aber nicht lohnt, irgendein...
Sag mal, .NET-Projekt zu machen.
Und dann irgendwie einen 60 MB self-contained...
Executable zu bauen oder so.
Moin.
Und deswegen müsste ich wahrscheinlich...
Mal eine Runde Python lernen in einem der nächsten Streams.
Oder zumindest mal auf...
Frischen.
Ja.
Übrigens, richtig cringe.
Passt mal auf.
Twitter.
Das muss ich euch zeigen.
Richtig lost.
Könnte man...
Wie sagt man?
Ja, sagt man auch immer dazu.
Telekom erleben.
Guck mal, wir haben sogar schon...
Wir haben sogar schon...
Passt mal auf.
Ein richtig hyper cringe Tweet von der Telekom letztens gesehen.
Hier.
Wusstet ihr...
So fail, Alter.
Guck mal.
Alter, Twitter.
Kannst du mal weggehen?
Hier.
Guck mal.
Wusstet ihr, dass heute nationaler Pink-Tag ist?
Und dass es spezielle Feiertage für Farben gibt?
Also, bei uns ist jeder Tag...
Magenta-Tag.
Und jetzt kommt der Cringe.
Jetzt kommt Ultra-Cringe.
Kommentiert mit einem Herz-Emoji.
Warum haben die hier eigentlich nicht dieses pinke Herz genommen?
Einfach nur ein Herz.
Kommentiert mit einem Herz-Emoji, wenn für euch auch jeder Tag ein Magenta-Tag ist.
Und wollen wir mal gucken, wie viele Leute ein Herz...
Ein Herz...
WTF?
Fuck.
Äh.
Alter.
Twitter.
Nicht viele, oder?
Nicht viele.
Wahrscheinlich sind das Telekom-Mitarbeiter.
Sechs Leute.
Sechs Leute haben...
Warte mal.
Haben die wirklich...
Das müssen wir uns mal am Firefox angucken.
Firefox kann mehr Emojis als Windows.
Haben die wirklich nicht das pinke Herz verwendet?
Die haben wirklich nicht das pinke Herz verwendet, Leute.
Wartet mal.
Seit wann verwendet Firefox...
Ach nee, das ist das Twitter-Emoji.
Nee, passt.
Die haben wirklich nicht das pinke Herz verwendet.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Der hätte man wirklich jetzt...
Aber nee, das war zu advancedes Social-Media-Zeug für die Telekom.
Aber das ist zwar nicht richtig cringe, Alter.
Red antwortet, wenn für euch auch jeder Tag ein Magenta-Tag ist, Mann.
Eigentlich, wisst ihr, ich hätte damit antworten müssen.
Vielleicht war das der Praktikant aus der Marketing...
Nein, das war sicherlich nicht der Praktikant.
Das war irgendjemand, der dafür wahrscheinlich mehr verdient, als wir alle zusammen.
Dafür, dass er solche krassen, five-headigen Marketing-Posts...
...macht.
Das ist ja das Schlimme.
Ein highly paid professional war das bestimmt sogar noch.
Naja.
Also.
Was hat denn YouTube heute zu bieten?
Ach, wir müssen uns, wo wir gerade dabei sind...
Zeigt mal ganz schnell.
Wie sieht es denn mit Battlefield-Spielen...
Okay, die sind immer noch mies.
Aber, immerhin, guckt mal, Leute.
Die sinken wieder nur langsam.
Also, wir sind wahrscheinlich...
Erst in einer Woche oder in zwei Wochen wieder auf fast null.
Der Vodafone-Tag.
Leute, ihr müsst mal Vodafone auf Twitter euch angucken.
Die haben den ganzen Tag, glaube ich, nichts Besseres zu tun, wie sich da mit der Telekom zu biefen.
Ihr müsst mal drauf achten.
Also, Leute, die auf Twitter schreiben...
Mein Internet sackt heute wieder.
Da kommt dann die Telekom an und...
Was weiß ich.
Irgendjemand schreibt auf Twitter...
Ähm...
Äh, äh, äh...
Vodafone, mein Internet ist heute wieder richtig unstable.
Und dann antwortet auf einmal die Telekom...
Wenn das bei Vodafone so lange dauert, wir können dir gerne ein Angebot machen.
Smiley, smiley.
Und dann antwortet Vodafone was drauf.
Habt ihr denn nichts Besseres zu tun?
Rennen euch die Kunden weg?
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Dann frage ich mich auch...
Haben die nichts anderes zu tun, oder was?
Dass sich die offiziellen Support-Kanäle da von Telekom und Vodafone...
Äh...
Was macht New World?
Wow!
Dieses Game...
Alter, guck mal.
Also, ich habe schon viele Games gesehen, die sind gelauncht und dann in der Bedeutungslosigkeit versunken.
Was ich aber ehrlich gesagt noch nie gesehen habe, ist ein Game, was bei Release knapp eine Million Spieler hatte.
Und es geschafft hat, innerhalb von...
Naja...
Zwei Monaten, drei Monaten, 90% seiner Spieler zu verlieren.
Das habe ich noch...
EVE Online wird wahrscheinlich immer noch bei was weiß ich, 60k oder so rumkrebsen.
So wie das...
Wobei, weiß ich gar nicht.
Achso, die meisten...
Spielen die meisten da überhaupt über Steam?
Ja, EVE hat immer ungefähr ähnlich viel, ja.
Man darf nicht vergessen, New World war ein MMO, was Client-Side-Hit-Detection hatte.
Bei einem MMO, das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Und die haben wirklich gedacht, das Spiel ist ready.
Ein MMO mit Client-Side-Hit-Detection.
Ich...
Ja, sehr Six-Head-Chat.
Wahnsinnig Six-Head.
Auf die dumme Idee kann nur Amazon kommen.
Generell.
Die ganze Entwicklung von New World ist einfach nur Painz-Champ.
Hätten die halt mal ein paar Leute nehmen sollen, die Ahnung von MMOs haben.
Chef im Freibad.
Der Bademeister.
Jawoll.
Wollt ihr immer wissen, was ein Bademeister verdient?
Eigentlich kenne ich Bademeister nur, wenn sie nerven.
Wenn sie dir irgendwie erzählen, du sollst, was weiß ich, da, äh, dich erst abtrocknen oder du sollst hier nicht so rumspritzen im Wasser, Gachi-Bass oder du sollst...
Nein, nicht Gachi-Bass, Leute.
Ähm, oder, keine Ahnung, hier, sollst nicht so viele, sollst nicht so viele Liegen blockieren oder sollst von der richtigen Seite ins Becken oder, ach, keine Ahnung.
Jetzt eigentlich, ich hab noch nie einen Bademeister wirklich in Action gesehen, dass da jemand retten musste aus dem...
Aus dem Becken.
If you sleep near your PC.
Ähm, eigentlich nicht mehr, nein.
Warum ist das so leise?
Warum ist das so leise? Ich hab das mega laut.
Das ist einfach broken, der Short.
Wow, geiler Tipp!
Die Festplatte, also ganz ehrlich, da würde ich erstmal die ganze RGB entfernen, wenn ich da nebenan pennen würde.
Ich bin jetzt leise, ja, ganz bestimmt, seh ich sofort.
Hier dran, guck da.
Warte mal, Teams hat dran rumgestellt.
Fällt mir gerade auf, weil...
Ich hab nicht 6, ne, normalerweise hab ich 79.
Da hab ich nur verguckt.
Tja.
So, also was schauen wir uns denn an?
Komm, es gibt doch bestimmt irgendwas.
Was halt, wir lassen uns...
Leute, der übliche Level-Capture...
Warum hab ich...
Okay, dreimal muss ich YouTube jetzt auch nicht offen haben.
Der übliche Level-Capture-Bait.
Wann würdest du dein nächstes PC-Upgrade vollziehen?
Ich warte...
Ich warte ja schon die ganze Zeit drauf.
Und zwar, entweder, dass der Kram verfügbar ist, oder aber, dass eine neue Nvidia-Grafikkartengeneration rauskommt.
Weil jetzt noch eine alte, eine, eine, eine, eine, eine Ryzen 5000-Dings-Generation kaufen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die heißt.
Sind es Ryzen 3?
Also, aktuelle Ryzen-Generation und eine aktuelle Nvidia-Grafikkartengeneration will ich eigentlich nicht mehr kaufen.
Aktuellen Intel könnte man sich kaufen, aber ich will eigentlich...
Ich habe drauf gehofft...
Ich habe drauf gehofft, dass vielleicht...
Eine neue AMD...
Ich wollte nämlich unbedingt mal wieder, seit irgendwie gefühlt 20 Jahren oder so, wieder einen AMD-Rechner haben.
Ja, die 5000er-Dinger meine ich.
So, und da sind die, die aktuell.
Da will ich mir aber eigentlich keinen mehr kaufen.
Ach, Zen 3, Ryzen 4-Wache-Notebook.
Ja, bessere Benahmung hätten mir ja auch nicht einfallen können.
Also, ich hätte am liebsten, ich hätte am liebsten, dass Nvidia irgendwie 4080 Ti's oder 4080 was auch immer rausbringt.
Oder 4090 oder so.
Für 30 Trillionen Euro, was das dann kosten wird.
Weil Grafikkarten sind halt nicht mehr so, dass man die sich einfach kaufen kann.
Das müsste ja mal mindestens irgendwie...
Eine Leber oder Niere kosten.
Weil ansonsten kannst du keine Grafikkarte dir mehr leisten.
So, und dann will ich irgendeine neue AMD-CPU.
Falls die was taugt, wenn nicht Intel.
Aber auf jeden Fall eine neue...
GPU-Generation von Nvidia.
Ist mir egal.
Weil, solange die im Desktop-Betrieb sich ruhig kühlen lassen, was ja mittlerweile kein Problem ist.
Du kannst ja im Desktop-Betrieb in der Regel die Rechner so machen.
Gerade wenn du einen relativ großen CPU-Kühler hast, dass die quasi nicht hörbar sind.
Meinen höre ich quasi so gut wie auch gar nicht jetzt.
Und wisst ihr, was das Wichtigste ist?
Wo kaum jemand dran denkt, wenn er denkt an Silent-Rechner oder...
Leise-Rechner.
Das Wichtigste.
Neben so Sachen wie Netzteil-Lüfter, CPU-Lüfter, Grafikkarte-Lüfter.
Wisst ihr, was das mit Abstand Wichtigste ist?
Oder neben Gehäuse-Lüfter.
Wo die Leute nicht dran denken.
Das ist ein Staubfilter.
Fürs Gehäuse.
Weil ansonsten ist es die längste Zeit leise gewesen.
Du brauchst ein Staubfilter.
Wenn du keinen Staubfilter im Gehäuse hast, dauert das Ding ein halbes Jahr und es wird immer lauter.
Einfach weil es sich halt zusetzt mit Staub.
Und dann muss es mehr kühlen und mehr lüften und alles.
Staubfilter.
Staubfilter ist das Wichtigste.
Staubfilter ist das Wichtigste überhaupt.
Wenn man will, dass es lange Zeit leise bleibt.
Ist das ein CPU-Lüfter?
Vom Namen her könnte es das sein.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Habe ich nicht was von gehört.
Oh, shit.
Tja.
Naja.
Mal gucken.
Dann hole ich mir halt ein fettes Netzteil.
Soll mir recht sein.
Ich dachte eigentlich, die Zeiten mit Rechner mit 1000 Watt Netzteil sind vorbei.
Das hatte man früher so zu.
Adlon XP-Zeiten, da hast du riesenfette 800-900 Watt Netzteile oder sowas reingebaut,
weil du die Dinger da auch übelst übertaktet hast und so.
Also ich glaube, ich habe mich nie mehr Hackermans gefühlt oder mehr Technik-Geek gefühlt an meinem PC
als zu Zeiten von Adlon XP und kurz davor, was war das?
Celeron D.
Oder Celeron 800 oder so, die du übertakten konntest von 800 auf irgendwie 1700 oder so.
Da kam ich mir vor wie der Bauer.
Bloß, dass es den Bauer damals noch nicht gab wahrscheinlich.
Der Auer.
Naja.
1000 Watt Netzteil heißt ja nicht, dass dein Rechner permanent 1000 Watt verbraucht.
Das ist nur, wenn er mal auch gerade in Spitzen das verbraucht, dass er dir nicht ausgeht.
Im Desktop-Betrieb.
Wird er wahrscheinlich weiter fast nix brauchen.
Okay, fast nix ist übertrieben, aber wenig verbrauchen.
Gerade im Vergleich zu den Rechnern von früher, die keine gescheiten Power-Save-Modi hatten.
Also auch CPU-technisch.
Das war ja normal, dass dann CPU-Lüfter da immer auf volle Pulle lief und dann CPU auch immer auf volle Pulle.
Das ist ganz schön viel, Idle.
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, Idle bist du vielleicht bei 30, 40 Watt oder so.
Aufgewacht zum Aufwachen streamen, Beste.
Dice Plan for Battlefield.
Okay, wir lassen uns jetzt...
Leute, wir lassen uns Level-Cap G-Baiten.
Zeig her.
Massive Level-Cap G-Bait.
Also der Plan von Dice für Battlefield 2042 ist ganz einfach.
Das habe ich schon 85.000 Mal gesagt.
Die haben das schon aufgegeben.
Das ist quasi schon geistig eingestellt.
Damit nur noch das Mindeste gemacht.
Der neue General Manager bei Dice hat sich über die Zukunft von Battlefield geäußert.
Call of Duty Warzone Season 4 ist hier.
Eine Live-Aktion Jedi-Modell.
Fallen Order TV-Show might be in the works and much more.
Ja gut, die cashen ja auch in allem rein, was geht.
Ob es qualitativ gut wird, sei mal dahingestellt.
...on this week in gaming.
The new General Manager at Dice shared some details about the studio this week.
In a blog post and several interviews, Rebecca Kutaz...
Love letter to the players, Leute.
...explained how the studio has...
Oder to the fans? Ach, keine Ahnung.
...restructured due to 2042's poor reception.
Kutaz explained that the majority of Dice's developers are still working on 2042,
Also, seriously, wenn die Mehrzahl der Dice-Entwickler an 2042 arbeiten, warum tut sich in diesem Game nix?
Das gibt einfach nur die Möglichkeit, sie erzählen Scheiße oder sie sind unfähig.
Ich weiß nicht, was davon schlechter ist.
...reaffirms Dice's commitment to the game, but didn't clarify if support could carry on beyond the previously advertised four seasons of content.
Nein, wird's auch nicht.
So ein dummes Geschwätz immer.
Also von Dice.
Das ist einfach so Marketing-Bullshit.
Dice waren ein FPS-Powerhouse.
Dice hätte einfach nur aufhören müssen, Scheiße zu sein.
Mit den letzten paar Battlefields.
Das ist alles.
Das ist einfach so leeres Marketing-Bullshit, Alter.
Das ist so, wie wenn EA vor ein paar Jahren erzählt hat,
EA hat ein Spiel, das sie nicht mehr spielen können.
Vielleicht könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern.
EA hat ja vor ein paar Jahren auch rausgehauen, so nach dem Motto, jetzt wird sich alles ändern.
EA ist ab jetzt eine Player-First-Company.
Haben sie gesagt vor drei, vier Jahren.
Und was hat es jetzt genau gebracht?
Ja, aber es geht auch wieder runter.
Wir haben doch gerade geguckt.
Natürlich ist es in a better place.
Es hat eine gescheite Map im Vergleich zu keiner.
Geil.
Es ist eine gescheite Map im Vergleich zu keiner.
Also müssen wir warten, ob DICE das Momentum behalten kann.
Ich frage mich ernsthaft, wenn wirklich der Großteil von DICE noch an Battlefield arbeitet.
Gibt es noch zwei weitere Varianten?
Entweder DICE hat kaum noch Mitarbeiter, weil sie die alle rausgeschmissen haben.
Oder mich würde wirklich mal interessieren, was machen die eigentlich den ganzen Tag?
Mieten die?
Die mieten wahrscheinlich.
Die machen Meetings.
Zu was auch immer.
Zum nächsten Battlefield.
Ich habe keinen Schimmer.
Okay, Warzone Season 4.
Vielleicht.
Vielleicht gucke ich mir Warzone nochmal an.
Ich habe ja mal eine Zeit lang recht viel gespielt.
Wenn Modern Warfare 2 rauskommt.
Also 2 des Reboots 2022.
Davon fange ich aber nicht wieder an.
Also guck mal.
Die haben das gleiche gemacht wie in einer Battlefield Season.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, die brauchen da keine 8 Monate für.
Und haben nebenbei auch nur die halbe Map überarbeitet.
Small coastal map with fast paced gunfights and numerous easter eggs for players to enjoy.
Einfach mal so.
But that's not all.
Nebenbei.
Einfach mal so nebenbei, wo DICE 8 Monate rumgemacht hat.
Season 4.
Both the T-800 and T-1000 Terminators from the Terminator movie franchise will be added.
They'll be part of a mid-season update as limited time bundles in store.
The Terminators will join the other 80s action movie cosmetics like Die Hard and Rambo.
Which were added to Warzone last year.
According to Star Wars Insider Christian Harloff, a live-action version of Jedi Fallen Order is in the works at Disney.
So überhaupt gar nicht.
The developers of Extraction Shooter Hunt Showdown have warned players who abuse a new glitch by rapidly changing the firing mode of the Lamat Mark II Revolver.
Okay, also wenn du möchtest, dass die Spieler einen Klitsch nicht ausnutzen, ist das mit Abstand schlechteste, was du machen kannst.
Den Spielern sagen, sie sollen den Klitsch nicht ausnutzen.
Das einfachste wäre, den Klitsch möglichst schnell zu fixen, dass ihn keiner mehr ausnutzen kann.
Aber wenn du den Leuten sagst, bitte bemacht etwas nicht, du kannst davon ausgehen, dass jetzt einfach 90% der Leute, selbst die noch gar nicht von der Existenz dieses Klitsches wussten, es jetzt machen werden.
Vielleicht wissen sie auch nichts, wie man fixen soll, ja.
Die Lüge zeigen einen unentscheidenden Powerboost, der dem Benutzer einen großen Vorteil gegen andere Spieler gibt.
Das hat Crytek schon erwähnt.
Leute, spielt jemand von euch ab und zu Hunt Showdown?
Wie stellt sich Crytek an mit dem Support?
Also hat man das Gefühl, die wissen, was sie machen?
Jetzt ehrlich, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich frag das jetzt nicht, weil ich wissen will, so nach dem Motto, hallo, alles Kacke.
Sondern einfach nur, ob die es gebacken bekommen.
Ich meine, wir haben uns vorher hier Battlefield angeguckt, die bekommen es nicht gebacken.
Wie sieht das bei Hunt Showdown aus?
Bekommen die das halbwegs gebacken?
... problem and actively working to resolve it.
They also noted...
The exploit could be detected and actions will be taken against players who abuse the glitch.
Ja, ja, ist klar, ist klar.
Actions against...
90% der Spieler werden diesen Glitch verwenden, wollen die 90% ihrer Playerbase bannen, oder was?
... but it might be a full-on ban.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
... a new anti-fraud system to combat in-game items from being sold by third parties.
This system aims to catch accounts trying to sell items to other players online.
These items may give users
an unfair advantage in-game...
Ja, das geht ja nicht.
Wenn schon, wenn schon, muss EA den Kram verkaufen.
It's built upon the current systems in games like FIFA and Apex Legends.
Also, also, es kann ja nicht sein, dass du zum China-Chinesen-Shop gehst, um dir Vorteile zu kaufen.
Du sollst, wenn schon, zu EA gehen, dir Vorteile zu kaufen, ist ja klar, oder?
... measures in place to detect accounts that have more in-game currency or items than they should.
The new patent tracks...
Übrigens, mich hat unter dem Diablo-Video einer Folge dissed, hat geschrieben,
ähm, Max, ich wär mit dran schuld, dass es so gekommen ist mit Diablo Immortal.
Und wisst ihr warum?
Weil ich damals in Diablo 2 Items auf Ebay verkauft habe.
Spiels Batman.
Also jetzt wisst, jetzt wisst ihr wen ihr haten müsst für Diablo Immortal.
Mich.
Extra stuff, EA's goal seems to be tracking down the players and third parties distributing the in-game items.
According to leaker Tom Henderson, Sony will be
hosting another State of Play Showcase next week.
It's rumored that new hardware will be revealed.
This includes a new pro controller alongside three new headsets.
The headsets will be part of Sony's new
In-Zone Gaming brand and be called the H9, H7 and H3.
All three will feature spatial audio.
However, only the H7 and H9 will be wireless.
They'll resemble the PlayStation 5 Plus headset, but with...
Moment, Sound aus dem Controller?
Oder...
Habe ich das jetzt gerade falsch verstanden?
...improved audio and build quality.
Online rumors suggest a new, stronger version of Valve's Steam Deck is on the way.
It's believed that the Steam Deck 2 will adopt AMD's new Zen 4...
Warte, ein neues Steam Deck?
Das erste ist doch kaum verfügbar gewesen.
...RDNA 3 architectures.
This means it'll boast four cores and eight threads, making it 20% faster than the current version.
Keep in mind that this is
unconfirmed
for now, and it's unlikely that a sequel
console will launch soon after the Steam Deck's recent launch.
Valve are also working on a new standalone VR headset codenamed the Deckard.
It utilizes similar hardware to the Steam Deck to power desktop class VR
experiences without needing to be tapped.
Ich frage mich, wie geil es die Leute finden, die sich jetzt ein Steam Deck gekauft haben,
wenn es jetzt direkt das nächste Steam Deck gibt.
Ich glaube, es verkauft sich ganz brauchbar, ja.
...regarding the Deckard yet.
Wenn ich sicher weiß, dass es Zahlen gibt.
Ja, Squad ist echt ein Game.
Das wollte ich seit Jahren, seit es das gibt, eigentlich schon spielen.
Aber ich habe immer Schiss, dass man da nicht richtig reinkommt, wenn man so spät einsteigt.
...update to great reviews.
Weil es ist einfach bei vielen...
Sagen wir mal, bei komplexeren Games ist es so, wenn du da später einsteigst, du
wirst erst mal geownt die ersten 100 Spielstunden, so nach dem Motto.
Weil du keine Ahnung hast.
...was du machst.
...as a new faction with unique weapons, a new map called the Black Coast, amphibious combat vehicles...
Hey, Leute, Leute.
Also wenn das einen nicht an Kark Island erinnert, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Das ist original Kark Island, die Starting Zone.
Seid mal ehrlich, oder?
Das ist, das ist eins zu eins Kark Island.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist das untere von diesem Schiff gemodelt nach Real Life
Vorbildern und dementsprechend sieht es halt da gleich aus.
Ja, halt mal.
Kark Island Rush.
Passt auf.
Ja, ja.
Ah ne, da ist Defender, der Kark-Noob.
Ich will ein Attacker-Video haben, please.
Attacker. Mensch.
Attacker.
Ja, wunderbar, das da.
Ja, guckt, guckt, seht ihr das im Hintergrund?
Guckt euch das an. Das ist original, ey.
Alter Heli, Mann, kann da irgendeiner normal starten?
Nope.
Die haben alle, die haben alle keinen Bock im Hangar zu starten.
Aber man hat's, man hat's eben gesehen im Hintergrund, ne?
Ja, am Start. Also man hat's hier, man hat's hier eben im Hintergrund gesehen.
Guckt mal, das ist, das ist original.
Der gleiche Hangar hier.
Coast amphibious combat vehicles in several improvements.
Unfortunately, the update did introduce a handful of new issues.
A few of them, like blurry scope optics for the Australian Spectre,
Black Coast game mode layers being skipped unintentionally, crashes and more
have been addressed in a recent hotfix.
According to
Muss man, ist da, is voice chat Pflicht?
To skateboard legend Tony Hawk,
remasters of Pro Skater 3 and 4 have been canceled by Blizzard Entertainment.
Earlier in the week, Hawk commented on the remasters during a Twitch stream.
He stated that the original plan was to remaster the first two games,
followed by the third and fourth.
However, that plan went out the window when the studio responsible was moved
to a support role for other studios by parent company Activision Blizzard.
Fans of the series are unsurprisingly disappointed, especially after the
remasters for the first two games were received so well.
Creative Assembly, the studio behind Total War and Alien Isolation, announced that
they are working on a new sci-fi multiplayer FPS called Hyenas.
Five teams of three are pitted against each other to loot space malls known as plunder ships.
Each team must escape the area with the most loot.
The devs have promised endless gameplay
opportunities, quick movement and lethal combat.
The game also features zero-g zones where teams will fight each other.
Es sieht nicht so aus, als würde es mich allein schon von der Optik her irgendwie ansprechen.
The annual gaming event Gamescom is still
going to go ahead this summer.
However, several notable publishers have publicly pulled out of the lineup.
A spokesperson from Sony confirmed that
this week they would not be making an appearance at the show.
Also ich weiß ja nicht, wie es euch ging,
als dass es auf Starfield, Starfield, Starfield heißt es.
Ich habe mir diese diesen Trailer ja auch
angeguckt und ich muss sagen, dieses geballerische, das sieht irgendwie,
wie soll ich sagen, irgendwie sehr.
Holprig aus oder sehr, tja, wie soll man das?
Soll man das beschreiben?
So träge und und.
Holprig, einfach, ich weiß nicht, es sah jetzt nicht so aus, so nach dem auch so
krass hier sieht aus, als fühlt sich das richtig gut anzuspielen, weiß nicht, so
einfach.
Nach nix.
Events along the way.
So, so, so, so, so.
Alongside Sony, Activision, Blizzard, Take-Two Interactive and Nintendo have
confirmed that they will not be attending Gamescom.
Ich würde schon angucken.
Their own event is more cost effective.
Das ist halt nix, das sieht einfach langweilig aus.
Tom Henderson talked about Skate 4 this week.
He claimed the highly anticipated title.
Man sieht, weil die Engine verwendet wurde.
Nee, ich sehe das nicht.
Ich würde mal auf Fallout tippen, aber das kann ja eigentlich nicht sein, weil
sie haben es mit Fallout 4 schon verkackt, damals irgendwas technisch halbwegs
aktuelles rauszubringen.
Und ich bezweifle, dass das jetzt noch mal, dass es jetzt noch mal erfunst.
Revealed in July recently leaked Gameplay
Clips and a talk of playtest has come back up, according to Henderson.
He stated that fans might get their hands on the game shortly after the reveal.
It's believed content creators and press
will get hands on experience in time for the reveal event.
EA CEO Andrew Wilson previously commented that Skate 4 would be launching very soon.
He said this during the most recent investor call.
Was ist mit den Leuten?
Los, wie nah willst du die Kamera dann noch ans Gesicht machen?
Took place last month.
Before we move on to the final topic of today's video, don't forget to hit that
subscribe button if you haven't already.
It's a great way to support the channel and
make sure that you're up to date on the latest gaming news.
According to Overwatch 2's Game Director, once the new game launches in October,
it'll completely replace the original game.
During a Reddit AMA session, the
leaving team competent company continues develop momentarily.
Das wird was!
Ok, Sie haben einen
obvious aber cleveren Schachzug gemacht.
Das Spiel wird free to play.
Das hätten die schon längst machen müssen.
Aber das könnte dem Spiel tatsächlich was bringen.
Also free to play ist das einzige, was ich mir vorstellen könnte, das dazu führt,
dass Overwatch 2 langfristig carne hat
und ... man kann jetzt nicht sagen,
Denn Overwatch 1 war auch ein Erfolg, das muss man ganz klar sagen.
Es haben Millionen gekauft, Millionen gespielt, aber es war halt einfach Langzeitsupport-technisch
und gerade diese typische Blizzard-Patch-Politik war halt richtig von Arsch.
Das war's für dieses Wochenende Gaming. Wie immer, danke für's Zuschauen und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's von LevelCap, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für dieses Wochenende Gaming.
Verwendet dann.
Ist nicht für die Allgemeinen, nur für Pressesachen.
Ja, dann ist es ja noch langweiliger.
Okay, zeig mal her.
Es ist die Exodia eines jeden Kritisierten.
Und vor etwa drei Jahren noch der Inhalt ungefähr jedes dritten Kommentars unter meinen Videos.
Ja, dann mach es doch.
Oh nein, ich hasse dieses Argument, Alter.
Dann mach es doch besser.
Das ist wie wenn du sagst, hey, keine Ahnung, bleib mal bei meinem aktuellen Thema, ja.
Battlefield 2022.
Battlefield 2022 hat eine miese Performance.
Und dann gibt es Leute, die sagen, ja, Max, dann programmier's doch besser.
Das ist doch scheißegal.
Ich hab das Spiel gekauft.
Ich will das Spiel spielen und das Spiel läuft nicht richtig.
Damit ich sagen kann, dass es scheiße läuft, muss ich das nicht selber besser können.
Diese Logik hab ich noch nie verstanden.
Ja, dann mach es besser.
Das schlimmste Beispiel, was mir einfällt von Leuten, die das wirklich mit voller Überzeugung,
Argumentiert haben, war, und das war so auch so der Moment, wo mir damals eingeleuchtet ist,
dass manche Leute einfach dämlich sind.
Das war, als ich noch Dark Edge of Camelot gespielt habe.
Und falls jemand auch in den Genuss gekommen ist, das in EU zu spielen, erinnert sich vielleicht
noch an die Goa Webseite.
Das ist das, was der Publisher, der das in EU rausgebracht hat.
Und die Webseite war einfach nur unterirdisch schlecht.
Mega beschissen war die Webseite.
So, und es gab immer im offiziellen Forum, oder auch im halboffiziellen Forum, gab es
Rumgeflame darüber, warum die Webseite so scheiße ist.
Und da hat dann allen Ernstes jemand drunter geschrieben damals, Leute, beschwert euch
nicht über die Webseite, setzt euch hin, lernt Webdesign, macht eine bessere Webseite
und zeigt sie dem Hersteller.
Sonst ist das doch überhaupt nicht konstruktiv oder sowas.
Und da dachte ich mir so, alter, Facepalm.
Wie dumm kann man eigentlich sein?
Ja, und seitdem.
Und seitdem fällt mir immer wieder auf, wie dämlich dieses Argument einfach ist.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Besser.
Und ich verstehe, wo das herkommt.
Fehler oder Ungereiche.
Ja, das ist genau, genau so ist es, Chad.
Das ist, wie wenn du ins Restaurant gehst und dein Essen ist was anderes, als du bestellt
hast oder so, ja?
Oder dein Essen hat noch gefrorene Gurken oder was auch immer drin, ja?
Und du sagst, Leute, was ist denn das?
Was habt ihr denn hier gemacht?
Und dann sagt der Koch erstmal, ha ha, null, du machst doch besser.
Das ist der F...
So ungefähr ist das, ja?
...Gereimtheiten in einer Sache aufzeigen, ist das eine.
Eine alternative Sache zu schaffen, die diese Fehler nicht aufweist, das andere.
Trotzdem ist man natürlich auch berechtigt, Kritik an Dingen zu äußern, die man selbst
nicht stemmen könnte.
Natürlich.
Andernfalls wäre Letterboxd die wahrscheinlich größte Sündenmeile der Welt.
Und dennoch hat sich die EU gedacht, was, wenn, doch.
Und versucht, mehrere soziale Netzwerke aufzubauen, die ihren eigenen Datenschutzbestimmungen gerecht werden.
Vor etwas über einem Monat hieß es plötzlich, die EU würde nach der unendlich langen Liste an Dingen,
die sie an etablierten sozialen Netzwerken auszusetzen hat, tatsächlich selbst aktiv werden und eigene ins Leben rufen.
Das Problem ist halt, das muss dann irgendjemand verwenden.
Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass irgendjemand darauf wechseln würde.
Unter den auffällig tiefsinnigen Arbeitstiteln EU-Video und EU-Voice will man mehr oder weniger YouTube und Twitter nachstellen,
aber eben stattdessen mit Datenschutz und finanziert von Öffentlichkeit.
Und das kann eine Menge bewegen.
Sich gegen die Monopol...
Okay, okay, kann, kann, lasse ich mir gefallen, wird es aber nicht.
Weil das, was dann am Ende rauskommt, eine absolute Ausgeburt der Hölle ist, die niemand verwenden will.
Giganten aufzulehnen kann zu einer Verbesserung der gesamten Branche führen.
Entsprechend weit oben waren meine Augenbrauen, als ich das erste Mal von diesem Projekt las.
EU-Voice basiert auf Mastodon.
Wahrscheinlich von dem ernüchternden Exodus-Scanner, dem Elon Musk drohte, Twitter zu kaufen.
Mastodon ist ein nicht-kommerzielles, dezentralisiertes Netzwerk.
Heißt, es gibt mehrere Server, die eigenverantwortlich von Privatpersonen, Institutionen oder in diesem Fall eben von der EU verwaltet werden und miteinander interagieren können.
EU-Video basiert währenddessen auf Peertube, ein ebenfalls nicht-kommerzielles wie dezentralisiertes Netzwerk, das zudem noch in Föderationen aufgeteilt ist.
So können sich mehrere Server zu einer Föderation zusammenbauen.
Leute, ich sag euch jetzt mal die Wahrheit.
Ihr habt zuallererst gehört, die ultimative Wahrheit, was Social Media angeht.
Die Leute scheißen auf Privatsphäre und auf Datenschutz.
Das interessiert die meisten Nutzer überhaupt nicht.
Das geht denen komplett am Arsch vorbei.
Da sieht man auch an den Antworten auf die üblichen Sachen mit so mit, du hast doch nichts zu verbergen oder warum sollte ich das machen?
Den meisten Leuten geht das komplett am Arsch vorbei, was Datenschutz.
Und was Privatsphäre angeht, alles was zählt ist, dass die Leute ein gutes Gefühl dabei haben, den Kram zu benutzen.
Gutes Gefühl bezieht sich jetzt nicht auf Privatsphäre und Datenschutz, sondern eben auf die Benutzung dieser Plattform.
Dass es ihnen irgendwie das gibt, was sie auf dieser Plattform erwarten.
Sei es auf Twitter irgendwelche Leute, die sich gegenseitig selbst loben können den ganzen Tag oder sich über irgendwas auskotzen können oder was auch immer.
Dass es ein gutes Gefühl beim Benutzen gibt und dass es so einfach ist, dass es auch die Umgebung,
die man selber zu einem anderen Thema bedienen kann.
Das wollen die Leute.
Das muss easy sein. Datenschutz ist egal.
Das siehst du beispielsweise auch schon daran.
Guckt euch Instant Messenger an.
Du hattest früher sowas wie IRC.
IRC war vom Protokoll her das simpelste und einfachste, was es gibt.
IRC ist im Prinzip, wenn du so willst, eigentlich immer noch der mit Abstand beste Chat und Chatprotokoll, was es gibt.
Kein XML-Scheiße, kein Jason rumgeschicke. Nein.
Einfach stinknormaler.
Plain Text mit Kommas und so.
Kannst du nichts dagegen sagen, aber IRC war halt nur was für die Ultra-Geeks damals.
So, und wenn ihr euch mal Messenger auf dem Handy anguckt, warum hat sich WhatsApp durchgesetzt?
Weil es einfach ist, weil es die Handynummer verwendet.
Keine extra Nummer, weil es dein Adressbuch schert, dass dann auch die Oma sieht, wenn der Enkel angemeldet ist oder der Enkel, wenn die Oma angemeldet ist.
Die scheißen auf Datenschutz.
Das ist egal.
Hauptsache, das ist einfach.
Und gibt ihr.
Das gibt ihnen irgendwie ein gutes Gefühl beim Benutzen.
Das ist alles.
Die Leute interessiert das nicht.
Uns interessiert das vielleicht.
Die meisten User scheißen drauf.
Die juckt das gar nichts.
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, wie die Casual-Noobs damals erzählt haben.
Oh, kennst du schon WhatsApp?
Kennst du schon WhatsApp?
Da kannst du, stell dir vor, da kannst du kostenlos SMS verschicken.
Da dachte ich mir auch immer, alter Painschamp.
Das sind keine SMS.
Das sind Instant-Messages.
Ganz normal übers Internet.
Wie alles andere auch, was es schon seit 20 Jahren gibt.
Aber es war halt easy.
Und WhatsApp hat es richtig gemacht.
Sie haben antizipiert, dass die Leute auf Privatsphäre scheißen würden.
Weil wir benutzen die offizielle Handynummer.
Und wir sharen Adressbücher und sonst was.
Seit drei Jahren, was ein Nokia 6510.
Sind das nicht so die alten mega fetten Dinger?
Ah, nee.
Okay, das ist richtig.
Das ist nicht ganz so alt wie für die fetten Nokia-Dinger.
Aber das ist auch schon äußerst oldschool.
Ja gut, da kannst du ja gar kein WhatsApp drauf benutzen.
Ob du willst oder nicht.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Also, ich habe schon ein iPhone.
Ich habe ein Handy, was ich WhatsApp drauf verwenden könnte.
Aber ich verwende kein WhatsApp drauf.
Ich hatte, ich überlege gerade, mein erstes Handy, das war auch ein Nokia.
Nokia C?
Nee.
Wie heißen diese super fetten?
303?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Fett.
Oder Fett ist jetzt schlecht.
Groß?
Alt, alt, alt.
Wie hießen diese richtig fetten Dinger?
Das da, das da.
Das hatte ich.
Genau das.
Dieses dicke.
Fünf?
Okay.
War das das?
Genau.
Dieser, dieser Klotz.
Das war mein erstes Handy damals.
Kann ich mich doch daran erinnern.
Richtig sick, alter.
Richtig, richtig fetter Klotz war das.
Release date.
Da fällt mir wieder auf, wie alt ich bin, Leute.
Muss man sich auch überlegen.
Ich war 14.
oder 1998.
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, oder?
Also ich nicht.
Ich bin im Kopf, also wenn du mich fragen würdest, wie alt bist, dann würde ich sagen irgendwie
22, 23 oder so.
Aber nein, Leute, ich werde dieses Jahr 38.
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, oder?
Oder?
Also ich nicht.
Also ich bin im Kopf, also wenn du mich fragen würdest, wie alt bist du, würde ich sagen
irgendwie 22, 23 oder so.
Aber nein, Leute, ich werde dieses Jahr 38.
gar nicht vorstellen 38 man dort nicht mehr lang da bin ich 40 es ist ja schlimm ganz ganz schlimm
ok wir gucken jetzt das video erst mal fertig bei den anderen föderationspartnern angezeigt
werden zudem funktioniert peer tube über wie der name schon vermuten lässt peer-to-peer technologie
so dass man als nutzer die selbst geschauten video andere nutzern zur verfügung stellt und
so server überlastung was eigentlich aus diesem aus dieser youtube alternative geworden wo du mit
views irgendwie crypto währung automatisch gemeint hast was war das denn noch mal da gab es doch so
eine gab es auch nur so eine sache wo die leute zeitlang gesagt haben ja max machst du dir auch
ein dings bums channel ich habe vergessen wie es heißt wo ich jemand gesagt haben da guckt keiner
youtube
ich weiß nicht ob das die tube wird kann sein ich weiß nicht mal wieder es hieß mit mir mit mir ist
ja es ist ja dauern schon wieder odyssee odyssee kann sein ja ich weiß nicht das da ich sind so
viele plattformen entstanden und wieder wieder verschwunden die letzten jahre über er weiter
technologie ist bei weitem nicht
nicht unumstritten. In anderen Peer-Typ-Instanzen, in denen verfassungsfeindliches Material veröffentlicht
wird, gilt man bei einer Wiedergabe über Peer-to-Peer juristisch auch gleichzeitig
als Anbieter des Inhalts.
Das ist schlecht.
Und da wurde ich langsam stutzig. Das wäre ja, bei ausreichender Beliebtheit der Plattform,
ebenfalls ein horrender Moderationsaufwand. Ein Aufwand, den die EU wahrscheinlich nicht
über künstliche neuronale Netzwerke regeln wird, wenn sie diese Praxis bei YouTube, Facebook
und Co. so oft anprangert. Und sowieso müsste dann die EU nicht auch Upload-
Dann müssten die sich mal mit ihren eigenen Gesetzen, die sie gemacht haben, auseinandersetzen
und feststellen, wie unpraktikabel das alles ist.
...Filter einsetzen, weil sie ja nach ihrer eigenen Richtlinie für die Urheberrechtsverstöße,
die andere Nutzer auf ihrer Plattform begehen, verantwortlich werden. Aktuell ist das aber
noch kein wirkliches Thema. Die Plattformen sind zwar beide schon live-
Jetzt mal seriously, da kommt doch eh nichts gescheit. Oh ja, die Plattform, die sieht
aber genauso aus, als will ich die unbedingt veröffentlichen.
...verwenden, ja. Aber man kann sich bei ihnen nicht registrieren,
weswegen ich meine Idee, dieses Video dort als Beispiel auch zu ver-
Ist das, ist das irgendeiner, der irgendein Material Design, ähm, Template von Github
runtergeladen hat und es dann für eine Videoseite verwendet, wo es gar nicht richtig passt?
Sieht so aus. ...veröffentlichen, verworfen hab.
Aktuell hat EU Voice 20 Accounts, von denen 14 im letzten Monat noch aktiv waren und etwa
1500 Beiträge. EU Video hat aktuell 20 Videos, von denen zwei in den letzten 30 Tagen veröffentlicht
wurden. Dabei sind einige nicht uninteressante- Also allein schon mit dieser Domain kommste
net weit. tubenetwerkeuropa.eu, wer zum Teufel soll denn sowas eingeben? 53 Views, das geht
ja durch die Decke. Das ist ja, das explodiert ja nahezu. 7 Views. Alter. Huiuiui. Da wird
YouTube aber ganz, ganz gehörig jetzt Angst bekommen. Äh, naja, das ist im Prinzip das,
was ich mir dachte, ja. Aber wetten, wetten, das hat wieder 50 Millionen gekostet oder so.
...technisch gut gemachte Videos, aber natürlich auch knapp zweistündige Präsentationen,
in denen ein Beamer-Bild schief abgefilmt wird. Und so wie es aussieht,
bleibt dieser Umstand auch so. Denn auch wenn das alles als Teil eines sogenannten
Alternative Social Media Pilot Programms bezeichnet wird, ist die Aufgabe, die diese
Plattformen erfüllen sollen, bei weitem keine vollumfängliche Alternative zu ihren etablierten
Pendants. Stattdessen werden EU Video und EU Voice für Presseveröffentlichungen und Public Relations
durch Institutionen der EU genutzt. Und das, es tut mir leid, finde ich äußerst dämlich.
Ich verstehe den
Drang, alternative Plattformen zu schaffen, damit man nicht immer zähneknirschend die Technologie nutzt,
die der eigenen Vorstellung von Datenschutz und Privatsphäre eigentlich diametral entgegensteht.
Aber wenn das dazu führt, dass exklusive Öffentlichkeitsarbeit eine Plattform aus
dem Boden gestampft wird, die noch gar keine Öffentlichkeit hat, dann senkt sich eine.
Stimmt schon. Vor allem ist der Scheiß wahrscheinlich unglaublich teuer gewesen wieder.
Ich meine, wir würden sowas wahrscheinlich in zwei Tagen machen, irgendeine Webseite mit 20 Videos drauf,
ja. Aber da hat es bestimmt wieder 50 Millionen gekostet.
Augenbrauen schnell wieder. In den Datenschutzbestimmungen beider
Plattformen spricht man von dem Bedürfnis, die USA aus der Datenverarbeitung auszuschließen,
indem man europäische Dienste für die Kommunikation nutzt, dass man auf Werbeeinnahmen und damit auch
auf personalisierte Anzeigen durch das Auslesen von Nutzerdaten verzichtet und dass man stets
das Minimum an Daten erhebt, das für eine moderne Funktionalität der Dienste notwendig ist.
Alles Dinge, die vielversprechend klingen, aber sich auf eine Aufgabe begrenzen,
dessen Sinn überschaubar ist. Ich kann es mir nur schwer vorstellen, dass EU Video und EU Voice
Plattform werden, die die normale Bevölkerung frequentiert aufruft, wenn sie nicht die
Möglichkeit hat, dort selbst Dinge zu produzieren. Ohne Scheiß. Das Wubblos Stream Archiv ist die
deutlich bessere Video Plattform im Vergleich zu EU Video. Und es hat vor allem das bessere Theme.
Ich meine, man kann auch seriösere Themes machen, aber das ist das Beste hier.
Und weiß, dass dort ausschließlich von EU Institutionen gepostet wird. Das wäre ein
bisschen wie ein eigenes Instagram, auf dem ausschließlich geairbrushte Wahlkampf-Porträts
hochgeladen werden. Aber ich mag nichtsdestotrotz den Versuch, etwas Bewegung in die Sache zu
bringen. Auch wenn sich auf EU Video und EU Voice auf absehbare Zeit nur verschiedene Behörden
gegenseitig für ihre mittelmäßigen PR-Videos liken und das vermutlich außerhalb des
Kreises kaum jemanden aus der eigentlichen Zielgruppe wirklich erreichen wird, ist es
trotzdem ein Experiment, dass, wenn es schon die EU nicht weiterdenkt, vielleicht von jemand
anderem aufgegriffen wird. YouTube, Twitter und Co. aus ihrer unendlichen Trägheit zwingt und
vielleicht endlich mal wieder etwas Neues, Innovatives auf diese Frau loslässt. Ich finde
den Gedanken aktuell auch total absurd, zu sehen, wie Influencer auf einer von der EU verwalteten,
dezentralisierten Video Plattform Produktplatzierung für umgesetzte Herangehensweisen
auszeichnet und mit der
Energieverbrauchskraft getroffen werden kann, mit ausreichend Umgepieselte Nahrungsergänzungsmittel
machen, aber hey, es wäre nicht das erste Mal, dass das Internet mich vom Gegenteil überzeugt. Deswegen...
Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher. Hier, guck mal!
Twitch Clip Archive. Archive Backend. PriceCham Frontend. Archive Frontend, hier! Da, ist das Archive Frontend.
Hog. Typescript. Ja, richtig, richtig nice.
Was habt ihr denn da? Ich hatte eine Geschichte. Kannst du mir das noch erzählen? Ich muss das erst nachhelfen.
So ein Handbuch bzw. Charme. Schau mal, wie- nails, ich habe ein Handbuch mangelt. Good morning video. Huge New Year, thanks for watching.
ja richtig richtig nice also nicht youtube das archiv so was können wir uns als nächstes
angucken 15 easy home automation ideas anyone can say okay wir machen nicht wir machen die
schnell den schnelldurchgang wir gucken uns einfach hier unten an time based lights speaker
volume geologie location doppel ideas bild in sensors hinten dieser erste anstalt sagt
brauche ich gucken ohne please ich habe mich heute schon über new world ausgelassen es reicht
jetzt spieler zahlen aber auch schon angeguckt how much pain software engineers in 2022 also
fang ist facebook netflix google alphabet nee ich weiß apple apple apple ja
amazon genau genau weil eigentlich ist es ja alphabet anstatt google gucken wir mal gucken
wir was software engineers da bekommen auf geht's software engineering is one of the highest paid
professions right now and the compensation er auf ich will es einfach nur ich will die zahlen
haben zeige ich her ob die wirklich am meisten bezahlen weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht ich
meine das ist auf jeden fall eines der
prestige trächtigsten sachen wo du als entwickler gewesen sein kannst ob die jetzt wirklich am
meisten bezahlen weiß ich gar nicht apple amazon okay weiser des facebook engineers to work
in the past few years mit 122.000 kommen in das als bekommen das überhaupt her
also du kriegst als du kriegst du kriegst im ja
hunderttausend
im jahr
100.000
122.000 Dollar und davon sind 41.000 Dollar in Aktien, oder wie?
Dann kannst du noch einen Bonus kriegen.
Oder kommt das noch obendrauf? Ach nee, das kommt obendrauf.
Ah, also du verdienst irgendwie so 180, 180k.
Wohlgemerkt, wir sind bei den Amis, ja?
Da ist das alles immer ein bisschen höher.
Was ist denn ein E4-Ingenieur?
Okay, das Video ist mir ein bisschen zu trocken.
Das ist wahrscheinlich die...
Okay, das werden wir wahrscheinlich nicht werden, aber das ist schon ein...
Boah, da kann man sich nicht beschweren, als was auch immer E8 ist, ja?
So, wie geht's weiter? Apple.
Ja, wahrscheinlich gibt's nur fünf Leute auf der Welt da, die das kriegen.
Ist das denn bei Apple reicht, dass man bei Apple ist?
So, Amazon.
Mich würde mal interessieren, was man bei Amazon Games so bekommt.
Aha, auch ordentlich auf jeden Fall.
Das ist schon... Das sind schon ordentliche...
Das sind wirklich schon ordentliche Hausnummern hier.
Aber man darf jetzt auch nicht von ausgehen, dass das da jeder verdient, ja?
Das ist, wenn du da in... Was will ich?
Da gibt's wahrscheinlich zehn Positionen pro Unternehmen, die das bezahlen dann oder so.
Google?
Google ist auch ordentlich dabei.
Conclusion.
Ah ja, gut.
Also, wir wissen, dass wir in oberen Positionen bei Google, Facebook und so viel Geld verdienen können, ja?
Das...
Das hab ich mir vorher auch schon gedacht.
Ob und wie lange Netflix da noch dabei ist, ist die Frage, ja?
Netflix hat ja grad so ein paar Probleme.
Was macht eigentlich der Netflix-Kurs?
Der ist etwas... Ah, gut, aber es ist alles...
Es ist alles mega abgekackt, ja?
Aber Netflix wohl irgendwie besonders.
Was machen... Moment, Leute, ich muss mal kurz meine Stonks gucken.
Sekunde, Sekunde.
Wie viel... Ob ich... Ob ich nochmal minus tausend oder so Stonks...
Ich verkauf den Kram eh nicht.
Ich warte, bis es wieder hochgeht.
Ähm...
Scalable.
So, zeig ich mal her.
Stonks. Was machen meine Stonks?
An error has occurred.
Okay, ich wurde ausgeloggt.
Super.
Ich muss mich neu einloggen.
Ich hab die Zugangsdaten hier grad nicht.
Unreal Tournament never dies.
Nö.
Beste.
Oh, das ist Toss-Musik.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht anmachen.
Der Bitcoin-Kurs ist auch...
Der Bitcoin-Kurs ist auch mega abgekackt.
Hacking a Samsung Galaxy for 6 Millionen Dollar.
Das ist der... Wollte ich grad sagen.
Das ist der Typ mit dem Krypto-USB-Stick.
Das war das letzte Mal...
Wirkte das schon ein wenig gestellt.
Keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich so ist.
14 Spiele, für die sich die PS5 wirklich lohnt.
Ich...
Okay, wir machen den Schnelldurchgang.
Also, was für Spiele sind das?
Demon's Souls.
Was ist das?
Return...
Sagt mir gar nix.
Final Fantasy Remake.
Kannst du auf dem PC auch spielen, hab ich aber keinen Bock drauf.
Astro's Playroom.
Das ist doch dieses Demo-Game, was dabei war, oder?
Das juckt mich auch nicht.
Für GTA 5.
Seriously.
Da muss ich doch keine PS5 holen.
Last Guardian.
Okay, dafür lohnt sich das.
Aber das Game kam ja schon ursprünglich mal für die PS3 oder so.
Wie fandst du...
Alter!
Geiler, geiler Job, GameStar.
Gut gemacht.
Devil May Cry 5.
Ja, meinetwegen.
Sackboy, a big adventure.
Meinetwegen.
Großsozio, meinetwegen.
Gran Turismo, juckt mich nicht.
Das wird sich tatsächlich lohnen.
Und das gab's ja auch schon mit dem PS4.
Na.
Easy.
Videos im Schnelldurchgang.
Also, Videos im Schnelldurchgang, ohne das Video zu gucken.
Da weiß man Bescheid.
Mathe-Vorlesung an der Uni Trier.
Nee, das muss jetzt nicht sein.
Marode Schienen, verspätete Züge, verärgerte Passagiere.
Ich weiß nicht, wo das kontrovers ist.
Das ist... ist so.
Oh, nee, wenn ich die...
Ich kann... kann... kann diese Aufmachung dieser Dokus teilweise nicht ab...
Okay, was soll ich mir...
Leute, ich bin heute irgendwie nicht gut drauf.
Ich bin... ich find alles kacke.
Merkt ihr das?
Ich bin... ups.
300 Frame Flicks.
Alles klar.
Wobei, ist das nicht normal?
Ich find immer alles kacke, oder?
Boomer.
Boomer Hater.
Aber wenigstens... wenigstens erzähl ich euch nicht, dass das früher besser war.
Meistens, ja.
Das stimmt schon.
Weil war's auch nicht.
So, was können wir uns denn sonst angucken?
Also...
24 Dollar Destroyed MacBook Pro.
Kein Battlefield jetzt.
Die Call of Duty spielt...
Die Call of Duty spielt viele für den DS.
Stream.
Lohnt sich das?
Sanitär, Heizungs-, Klimatechnik.
Wie schnell dein Geld mit Fishing weg ist?
Wenn man sich dumm anstellt, relativ schnell, ja.
Okay, das gucken wir jetzt.
Das wird... das wird wieder ein absoluter...
Okay, mal gucken.
Manchmal...
Manchmal machen die ja auch ganz gute... ganz gute Sachen, ja.
Ähm...
Leider sind die Beiträge, die wir in letzter Zeit gesehen haben,
ein bisschen weit weg von dem, was in der Überschrift stand.
Erinnert euch noch daran, dieses irgendwie...
Susi wird Cyberpolizistin?
Ich weiß nicht, wie die hieß, aber ich...
Irgendwie ist das in der Richtung.
Obwohl, legit nicht eine Cybersache in diesem ganzen Beitrag vorgekommen ist.
Der Stubenhocker, danke schön für den Zap.
Okay, auf geht's.
Und ich bin eben gerade, glaube ich, zumindest Opfer von Online-Fishing geworden.
Und ich rede jetzt hier im Haus rum.
Ich bin auf 180.
Wir haben eine SMS gekriegt.
Morgen, KS.
750 P, 50 FPS.
Pal lässt grüßen.
Von einer Haspa angeblich, von einer Hamburger Sparkasse.
Und dann hat...
Also der ist doch für das Video vorher erstmal die Treppe hochgelaufen,
dass er jetzt irgendwie etwas...
Ähm...
Mehr außer Puste klingt, oder?
Hat sich da über so einen Online-Link eingeloggt.
Und...
Dann hat er jetzt angerufen gerade.
Irgend so ein Typ...
Aus Indien?
Und jetzt hat sie ihm zwei Tons durchgegeben.
Und ich glaube, wir haben tausende Euros verloren dadurch jetzt auf jeden Fall.
Und dann ist das weg.
Also sie haben...
Ja, wenn man sich blöd anstellt.
Keine Chance, dass...
Alter, wer kippt denn übers Telefon irgendeinem random Inder-Tons durch?
Ach, Gott.
Sie sollten zumindest nicht darauf vertrauen, dass die Polizei jetzt das Geld für Sie zurückholt.
Mich kriege ich jetzt noch so einen Hals, wenn ich da nur drüber nachdenke, was da passiert ist damals.
Aber ich habe dann auch sofort gedacht...
Aber gut.
Wenn das Geld sowieso...
Aber Leute, Leute.
Gut, dass ihr zufälligerweise mit der Kamera dabei wart, wo das passiert ist.
Haben wir ja nochmal Glück gehabt, dass das alles echt so passiert ist.
Dann will ich zumindest irgendeinen Film machen aus dieser ganzen Misere.
Und ich war auch sofort schockiert, wie schnell das da alles ging.
Sofort war das Geld weg.
Die Banken konnten nichts mehr machen.
Naja, wenn du eine Online-Überweisung machst, ist das halt weg.
Und ich habe mich irgendwie gefragt, dürfen die das?
Dürfen Banken mein Geld einfach so schnell weitergeben?
Natürlich.
Und so...
Wenn du eine Überweisung machst, willst du doch eigentlich, dass es überwiesen wird, oder?
Fängt alles an.
Okay, auf geht's.
Am späten Freitagnachmittag bekommt meine Frau eine SMS.
Der Absender, angeblich die Hamburger Sparkasse, kurz Haspa.
Also, das Erste, was einem da schon auffällt, ist, dass da sehr geehrter Kunde steht.
Wenn da nicht steht, sehr geehrter Herr Cute Chat, dann mache ich mir schon mal Gedanken.
Also, wenn da nicht der echte Name steht, oder sei es so der Nachname,
dann würde ich schon mal stutzig werden.
Die Nachricht?
Wenn sie nicht sofort einen Sicherheitsupdate durchführt, kann sie ihr Online-Banking nicht mehr nutzen.
Auf einer falschen Webseite lockt sie sich ein.
Jetzt haben die Betrüger ihre Kontos...
Ja, nein, nein, nein.
Ich sage auch nicht, dass ich auf den Namen direkt reagieren würde,
aber es ist schon mal verdächtig, wenn nicht der Name drinsteht.
Oh, ein roter Pfeil.
Excellent.
Ne, das erzähle ich jetzt nicht.
Ich wollte gerade was Blödes erzählen, aber...
Wo sind wir denn hier stehen geblieben?
Ich habe...
Ah, hier.
Ich meine, die Webseite ist immerhin schon mal kein gebrochenes Deutsch
und irgendjemand, der schon mal ein paar Sätze auf Deutsch fehlerfrei geschrieben hat, hat die erstellt.
Ein Bit Poggers.
Und ihr Passwort.
Damit melden die...
Erzählen? Okay.
Also, was ich sagen wollte ist,
weil irgendjemand gerade geschrieben hat,
im Zweifelsfall bei der Bank anrufen.
Bei mir war mal die GEZ, als ich noch in der alten Wohnung gewohnt habe,
als ich meine Ausbildung angefangen habe.
Und da kam irgendein Typ und hat gemeint,
sehr geehrter Herr Max,
Sie wissen ja sicherlich,
dass, wenn Sie jetzt Geld verdienen und bla bla bla,
wo ich mir immer gedacht habe,
woher wissen die das eigentlich?
Und ich wollte eigentlich direkt zumachen,
aber ich habe dann beim Hessisch,
also ich habe dann geguckt,
gefragt, wo kann man denn anrufen?
Dann habe ich nachgeguckt,
dann habe ich dort angerufen,
habe gesagt,
ist ein Herr, ich sage jetzt mal Herr Müller,
der sagt, der ist vom Hessischen Rundfunk,
ist der wirklich bei Ihnen?
Und da meinten die, ja, der ist,
oder nicht beim Hessischen Rundfunk,
doch, vom Hessischen Rundfunk,
ist der wirklich bei Ihnen?
Und da meinte der Hessische Rundfunk,
nö, den kennen wir nicht.
Den kennen wir nicht.
Die sind, ja, der sagt, der ist ja von der GEZ.
Und dann kamen die,
ja, die haben ja mit dem Hessischen Rundfunk nichts zu tun.
Und warum hat der denn einen Ausweis vom Hessischen Rundfunk?
Zumindest, zumindest,
ging das dann irgendwie 10 Minuten,
ob er es denn ist?
Dann habe ich gesagt, ich rede nicht mit ihm
und habe die Tür wieder zugemacht.
Richtig, richtig kackspastmäßig von mir, ey.
Aber ich muss dazu sagen,
wir haben damals,
ähm,
wahrscheinlich schon mehr GEZ bezahlt,
als die meisten, ja.
Mehrere Wohnungen,
also,
was er von mir wollte, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Ich sehe es zumindest nicht ein,
ich wollte mit dem nicht reden.
Ja.
Da hat er aber einen Ausweis, da stand irgendwas von Hessischem Rundfunk,
drauf.
Ich fand es halt,
ich fand es halt damals sehr merkwürdig,
dass die,
gesagt haben, sind vom Hessischen Rundfunk,
gar nicht vom Hessischen Rundfunk waren
und dass der wusste,
dass ich eine Ausbildung angefangen habe
und jetzt Geld verdiene und deswegen was bezahlen muss.
Was ja schwachsinnig ist, weil wir damals schon bezahlt haben.
Und nicht nur einmal.
Naja, egal.
Wir gucken jetzt mal weiter.
Also, Fisch, wird weiter gefischt.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Hier.
Also, zumindest ist es schon mal eine ganz gut gefakete Website,
muss ich sagen.
Also, da muss man sagen,
der Fischer hat sich durchaus, durchaus Mühe gegeben.
... für ihre Kontodaten und ihr Passwort.
Damit melden die sich bei ihrem Konto an
und geben eine Überweisung durch.
Tja.
Jetzt fehlt den Betrügern nur noch die TAN.
Um diese zu bekommen, ruft ein Betrüger meine Frau Kelly auf dem Handy.
Ja, das ist ja auch kein Problem.
Das ist ja überhaupt kein Problem,
ein gültiges SSL-Zertifikat dafür zu bekommen.
Das ist ja auch,
die Domain gehört den Fakern ja wahrscheinlich wirklich.
Let's Encrypt, gutes.
Warum die ein kaputtes Handy haben?
Wahrscheinlich, dass es authentischer wirkt oder so.
Jetzt ruft der indische Microsoft Support an und sagt,
er ist von der Sparkasse.
This is Peter.
Old Don.
... die an.
Sie ist Amerikanerin und kennt sich mit deutschem Online-Banking nicht aus.
Und dann steht er damals auch noch hasbar im Display.
Wie haben die das hingekriegt?
Absender, Absender-Telefonnummer faken, oder?
Wie krieg, wie geht das?
Das ist mir jetzt neu.
Wie krieg ich, dass es so aussieht, als ist es im Telefonbuch, obwohl es das nicht ist?
Kann man irgendwie die Absender-Telefonnummer faken?
Hasbar im Display.
Es war ein Mann, er klang sehr professionell und bestimmt und hat gesagt, dass er von der Haspa ist.
Und sie machen einen Sicherheits-Update und dafür braucht er einen TAN.
Er sagt, dass es...
Das ist immer...
Es...
...verdächtig, wenn ich random Leute anrufe und sage, sie brauchen eine TAN.
...wäre sehr...
Okay, es war ja nicht random.
...und ich habe gedacht, ja, ganz einfach, ich kann das machen und habe ich ihm...
Das ist ja schon clever gemacht von dir.
...so eine Scheiße, man weiß ja, dass man...
Ja, ganz ruhig.
Das ist aber tatsächlich clever gemacht, oder?
Ich meine, jemand, der sich da noch nie Gedanken drüber gemacht hat, der fällt da drauf rein.
Also...
Was?
Also, ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass die meisten Leute...
...da könnte auch sowas reinfallen, die sich damit noch nicht näher auseinandergesetzt haben.
...man das nicht machen kann und man weiß doch auch, dass man keine...
Aha, aber ich habe auch...
Ja, das ist doch jetzt...
Naja.
...ignoriert und sie hat ihn nicht richtig verstanden.
Sie ist halt eben auch keine deutsche Muttersprachlerin und ich bin jetzt...
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was wir jetzt machen sollen.
Es ist Freitagabend.
Keine Ahnung, Freitagabend hat keine fucking Bank mehr auf.
Genau deswegen haben sie diese SNS geschickt.
Ein ziemlich ausgeklügelter Plan, der sogar IT-Experte Vincent Haupert beeindruckt.
Haupert forscht seit Jahren zur Sicherheit von Online-Banking und hat mit spektakulären Hacking-Angriffen Lücken in Banksystemen aufgedeckt.
Ja, deswegen, am Telefon würde ich nie eine TAN durchgeben, aber jemand, der...
Also, in dem Fall verstehe ich schon, warum die da drauf reingefallen ist.
Die hat wahrscheinlich nicht so die großen Plan von Technik insgesamt.
Die hat sich noch nie um dieses Angriffsszenario Gedanken gemacht.
Und wenn die vom deutschen Online-Banking auch keine Ahnung hat, wer weiß, wie das woanders funktioniert.
Ich kann schon nachvollziehen, warum die da drauf reingefallen ist.
Ich meine, ich würde nie...
Ich würde nie...
Ich würde nie Links anklicken, die ich random aufs Handy bekomme, wo drinsteht, ich muss jetzt irgendwas bestätigen.
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass es mittlerweile so ist.
Also, mittlerweile sind die meisten Überweisungen ja innerhalb von...
Weiß nicht, wie das heißt hier, Instant-Überweisungen oder so.
Mittlerweile geht das relativ zackig mit Überweisungen.
Und in der Regel ist es auch direkt weg.
Aber keine Ahnung, ob das ist, wenn es Freitag übers Wochenende geht.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ob das am Wochenende noch irgendwo hängt.
Ich meine, es spricht ja eigentlich überhaupt nichts dagegen, dass Überweisungen auch...
Am Wochenende gehen, ja.
Rein technisch gesehen, aber...
In dem Fall hier war das extrem gut gemacht.
Also, ich fand die ganze SMS auch sehr authentisch.
Also, dass der Absender zum Beispiel hasbar ist, eine eigene Domain dafür zu registrieren.
Auch fand ich es relativ clever gemacht, dass man diese Verfahren SZ genannt hat,
weil das ist die Sicherheitseinheit, wenn man so will, von den Sparkassen.
Wenn man das jetzt oberflächlich googelt, dann findet man da erstmal was, was durchaus plausibel klingt.
Also, von daher glaube ich schon, dass das aktuell State-of-the-Art ist.
Doch selbst beim State-of-the-Art gibt es eindeutige Wahlenweise.
Die SMS.
Banken kommunizieren nie per Kurznachricht.
Die Webseite.
Deutsche Banken haben in der Regel keine .com-Adresse und viele der Links führen sogar ins Leere.
Banken kommunizieren nie über Kurznachrichten?
Das stimmt nicht.
Ähm...
Also, mein...
Unabhängig von den...
...normalen Sachen mit einloggen oder sonst was.
Und...
Bei...
Ich sag jetzt nicht die...
Nicht die...
Nicht den Name.
Aber ich weiß, meine Mutter kriegt öfters...
Nachrichten...
Von ihrer Bank.
Von der...
Von der richtig...
Von der richtig echten Bank.
Dass sie sich mal wieder irgendwelche E-Mails angucken muss im Postfach und...
Und Zeug.
Also, das würde ich jetzt so gar nicht unterschreiben.
Was war jetzt an der Webseite?
Banken kommunizieren nie per Kurznachricht.
Die Webseite.
Deutsche Banken haben in der Regel keine .com-Adresse und...
Naja.
Also, das hätte auch genauso gut eine .de-Adresse sein können.
Ich meine, eine Adresse zu registrieren, die irgendwie passt und dann...
Also, ob das jetzt...
Das würde ich...
Das weiß ich nicht.
Viele der Links führen sogar ins Leere.
Der Anruf.
Nach TANZ-Fragen echte Bankmitarbeiter...
Das stimmt.
Nie.
Also, ich würde im Leben keine TAN durchgeben.
Aber immerhin bemerken wir es schon Minuten später.
Da muss doch noch was zu machen sein.
Mein erster Gedanke, schnell die Notfallnummer anrufen.
Aber schnell geht hier überhaupt nichts.
Geben Sie bitte jetzt die 8-stellige...
Wisst ihr?
Der war so...
Die waren so geschockt, dass sie sich gedacht haben,
nehm mal live auf.
Ich mach dir jetzt einen Fernsehbeitrag.
Und dann kann ich das Konto zwar sperren lassen,
aber an der Überweisung selbst gibt es nichts mehr zu rütteln.
Denn sie wurde ja mit unserer TAN bestätigt.
Und wenn dann natürlich das Geld transferiert ist,
dann haben Sie bei einer getätigten Überweisung
oft keine Möglichkeit mehr, dieses Geld dann auch zurückzuholen.
Was aber grundsätzlich erfolgt,
und deswegen war es genau richtig, dass Sie dort auch angerufen haben,
man versucht natürlich trotzdem,
über Möglichkeiten dann eben einen Rückruf zu starten.
Aber in der Regel ist es bei einer
automatisierten Überweisung einfach zu spät.
In unserer Verzweiflung, der Nächste versucht das Geld zu retten.
Zum Geldautomaten fahren und das eigene Konto leer räumen.
Hä?
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Der Geldautomat bezahlt dir das doch gar nicht mehr aus.
Das ist doch schon weg.
Hä?
Ha...
Wir waren jetzt bei der Sparkasse und haben alles, was wir konnten, abgeholt.
So, 1000 Euro, mehr geht nicht an einem Tag.
Das heißt, jetzt ist unsere Hoffnung gewesen,
dass man, dass dann das ganze Geld, was wir quasi überwiesen haben,
ja dann nicht mehr auf dem Konto ist und nicht mehr genommen wird.
Race Conditions, ja.
Die haben nicht schnell genug vom Automat...
Wenn das ging, Leute, stellt euch mal vor,
dann würdest du dich mit dem Handy, mit Online-Banking,
vor den Automat stellen, 1000 Euro überweisen
und dann 1000 Euro abheben.
Oder hättest du doppelt 1000 Euro.
Ganz bestimmt.
Ganz ungefähr.
Ganz heute, dass wir uns auch in dieser Situation
insofern nachvollziehen, wenn du wirklich Panik hast,
machst du komische Dinger, die nicht wirklich Sinn ergeben.
Aber das ist natürlich, ich habe gerade mit meinem Bruder telefoniert.
Unlimited Money Clips.
Sparkassen hassen diesen Trick, genau.
Das ist natürlich ein absolut idiotischer Trugschluss,
weil das Geld war ja schon vorher weg.
Und das Einzige, was jetzt passiert ist,
wir haben das jetzt abgehoben
und wir sind dann jetzt mega im Dispo.
Tja.
Direkt danach fahren wir zur Polizei in Pinneberg
und erstatten Anzeige gegen Unbekannt.
Wir bekommen eine Vorgangsnummer und die Information, dass unser Fall an die Cybercrime-Unit weitergeleitet wird.
Ich meine, es wäre natürlich durchaus sinnvoll, wenn die Sparkasse eine Hacking-Cybercrime-Notfall-Hotline hätte, wo auch tatsächlich Menschen erreichbar sind.
Also, das wäre ja tatsächlich sinnvoll. Und es wäre ja vielleicht auch sinnvoll, dass man bei sowas einen Schutzmechanismus einbaut, den man vielleicht sogar freiwillig aktivieren kann, so nach dem Motto, Überweisungen gehen nur mit einer Stunde Verzögerung raus.
Das könnte man ja technisch ohne Probleme alles machen. Ja, haben sie doch. Ne, da war ja aber keiner dran, der ihnen helfen konnte. Da war irgendein Anrufbeantworter dran, wo du dein Konto drüber sperren konntest.
Also, man könnte da durchaus, denke ich, Sicherheitsvorkehrungen treffen, wenn man will, dass das nicht möglich wäre.
Diese Einheit sitzt in Bad Segeberg. Monate später, bei den Recherchen zu meinem Film, treffe ich hier Robert Nehring, der seit Jahren gegen Kriminelle im Internet ermittelt.
Von ihm erfahre ich, allein in Schleswig-Holstein haben Täter mit vergleichbaren Maschen wie bei uns in den letzten zwei Jahren mehr als 1,5 Millionen Euro erbeutet.
Das ist ja nicht so einfach.
Sie sollten zumindest nicht darauf vertrauen, dass die Polizei jetzt das Geld für Sie zurückholt.
Also es ist schon gut, wenn Sie selbst tätig werden und die Banken, von denen Sie zumindest wissen, selbst kontaktieren.
Denn bei der Polizei kann das durchaus sein. Sie zeigen das Ganze jetzt am Freitagnachmittag an. Da wird sich ein Ermittler frühestens am Montag der Sache annehmen.
Ha, wenn überhaupt. Wahrscheinlich dauert das drei Wochen, bis sich das irgendeiner anguckt.
Könnte das Geld ja schon alles weg sein.
Also, je schneller die Informationen, desto schneller die Hilfe.
Unser Problem?
Wir haben beim Anruf bei der Hotline unser Konto gesperrt und damit keinen Zugriff mehr, können also noch nicht mal nachschauen, an wen das Geld gegangen ist.
Wenn Sie erstmal gar nichts haben, dann ist der erste Schritt, dass wir Sie fragen, bei welcher Bank sind Sie.
Andererseits können wir fragen, da Sie eine SMS bekommen haben, da ist ein Link drin und dieser Link führt auf eine Domain.
Und diesen Hoster können wir zum Beispiel dann kontaktieren und fragen, wer hat bei dir denn diesen Webspace gerade gemietet?
Und wie wird er bezahlt? Und dann folgt man wieder dem Weg des Geldes.
Meistens ist der Weg des Geldes die sicherste Möglichkeit, den Täter zu ermitteln.
Das klingt durchaus logisch, ja.
Nur passiert all das leider nicht am Wochenende. Weder bei der Bank, noch beim Webseiten-Hoster, noch bei der Polizei.
Doch, doch, doch.
Beim Webseiten-Hoster passiert das auch am Wochenende.
Da könnt ihr sicher sein.
Jeder Webseiten-Hoster, was heißt Webseiten-Hoster?
Jeder Hoster oder jeder Cloud-Anbieter oder was auch immer, der auch nur ernst, ansatzweise ernst zu nehmen ist,
hat 24-7 Leute da.
Das passiert da auch am Wochenende.
Bei deutschen Behörden und deutschen Banken mag das nicht am Wochenende passieren.
Bei Hostern garantiert auch am Wochenende.
Die Sache ist halt nur die, wenn du da anrufst beim Hoster, werden die das nicht sperren.
Wenn du da anrufst, werden die das nicht sperren. Da muss die Polizei anrufen.
Das macht die am Wochenende nicht.
Und ob die überhaupt das sperren, nur weil einer von der Polizei anruft, ist auch fragwürdig.
Aber was ich schon erlebt habe am Wochenende ist, das kann ich euch jetzt ja an der Stelle, kleine Story am Rande.
Wir hatten mal von irgendeinem, ich glaube irgendeinem polnischer Anbieter war das.
Der hat, ich überlege gerade, hat der unser WordPress gehostet?
Auf der Arbeit? Nee, nee.
Also, es wurde versucht, ein WordPress, es ist ausgerechnet auch wieder WordPress, immer WordPress war sowas, ja.
Es wurde versucht, auf ein WordPress-System von uns zuzugreifen die ganze Zeit.
Und zwar von einer polnischen IP.
Und wir haben, ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher, wie wir das rausgekriegt haben.
Wir haben geguckt, dem gehört das und das gehörte irgendeinem polnischen Hoster.
Und die konnten nur polnisch oder gebrochen englisch.
Nicht die polnischen Switches, das war wieder was anderes.
Das war irgendein WordPress.
Und da haben die da angerufen, unser 24-7 Support.
Oder ich nenne es mal nicht Support.
Es ist ja eigentlich ein 24-7 Operation Center oder ich weiß gar nicht, wie man genau das bei uns eigentlich nennt.
Haben dort angerufen, die haben auch am Wochenende Leute erreicht.
Haben gesagt, hier, es geht ein Angriff von einem ihrer Server aus auf andere Systeme.
Und da haben die sich sofort drum gekümmert.
Also, da muss man schon sagen, also da bei Hostern, die da ein bisschen was auf sich halten, geht das auch mal schneller.
Also, wenn du bei der richtigen Nummer anrufst, je nachdem.
Also, da muss ich sagen, selbst bei kleinen Klitschen-Hostern habe ich damit eigentlich ganz gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Dass sie jetzt nicht die Domain abschalten, nur weil du da anrufst und sagst, ich wurde von dieser Domain aus gescamt, das ist klar.
Du kannst ihnen ja viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Aber im Falle von irgendwie einem Rechner, der versucht andere Sachen zu dedossen oder sonst was, das kriegen die ja auch mit.
Also, wenn du es ihnen sagst, können die das ja auch überprüfen, was da dran ist.
Also, das ging tatsächlich relativ schnell.
Und die haben das dann auch innerhalb von ein paar Stunden abgeschaltet.
Die Spiegel-Dokumentation.
Die Spiegel-Dokumentation, nee.
Ich will jetzt erst mal wissen, was jetzt hier rauskommt.
Für morgen, für Samstag, eine Bank gefunden, die einzige hassbar angeblich, Hamburger Sparkasse, die tatsächlich offen hat an einem Samstag.
Der nächste Morgen.
Keine 15 Stunden sind seit dem Betrug vergangen.
Wir haben alles, was möglich war.
Aber es ist schon schlimm, dass die keine Hotline haben, oder?
Ich finde es wirklich sehr bedenklich, dass die Sparkasse keine Hotline hat, wo du Menschen erreichen kannst für solche Fälle.
Warum nicht?
Warum gibt es sowas nicht?
Ich meine, ernsthaft, das ist ein riesen Ding.
Und die Sachen sind auch nicht umsonst auf Freitagmittag getimt.
Was der Kundenberater am Schalter machen will, na ja, vielleicht Leute anrufen.
Vielleicht hat er irgendwelche internen Service-Nummern, wo man in Hacker...
Ich meine, ernsthaft, guckt mal.
Es könnte doch auch durchaus sein, dass irgendein Hackerman Freitagabend, ähm,
irgendeinen Sparkassenserver übernimmt und da irgendwelche kriminellen Dinger auf die Homepage schreibt.
Um es jetzt mal die einfachste Sache zu nennen.
Ich meine, in Wirklichkeit würde er das wahrscheinlich so machen, dass er sich nicht direkt zu erkennen gibt, sondern versucht, ein paar Sachen abzugreifen.
Da muss es doch auch Leute geben, die dort hingehen und den Kram ausschalten am Wochenende.
Stellt euch vor, stellt euch vor, irgendwie der SSH-Zugang zu einem Sparkassen-Webserver ist nicht richtig.
Ja.
Das ist vielleicht nicht so richtig gesichert.
Irgendjemand bekommt das...
Kommt da rein, macht ein fettes Hakenkreuz auf die Sparkassenseite.
Da muss es doch auch am Wochenende jemand geben, der das weg macht.
Kann doch nicht sein, dass das 48 Stunden da ein Hakenkreuz auf der Sparkassenseite ist.
Das... Die haben garantiert, Leute!
Aber wahrscheinlich halt nicht für sowas.
Warum kannst du keine Hotline erreichen?
Warum kannst du keine Hotline erreichen, wo wirklich du mit jemand am Wochenende telefonieren kannst?
Das ist tatsächlich, das ist wirklich, finde ich, bedenklich.
Gehoben, dann unser Konto gesperrt, Anzeige bei der Polizei erstattet
und haben keine Ahnung, ob das hilft.
Aber da muss doch noch was zu machen sein.
Der Typ am Schalter ist wahrscheinlich planlos.
So, da haben wir eine Sparkasse.
Sieht ziemlich scheiße aus, muss man einfach mal ganz ehrlich sagen.
Die Chancen, dass man das zurückkriegt, sind sehr gering.
Wir wissen jetzt auch die genaue Summe.
3.333 Euro wurden vom Konto abgebucht.
Warum nicht 1,337? Okay, das ist weniger, aber...
Und 33 Cent, vielen Dank.
Das heißt also, das ist all ihr Erspartes.
Das ist wirklich faktisch alles, was da drauf war.
Moment, die hatten ein Konto, wo 333...
Nicht schlecht.
Wir haben jetzt allerdings auch die Kontodaten desjenigen.
Wahrscheinlich ein Fake-Name von irgendeiner Online-Bank
mit einem geklauten Personalausweis.
Aber was weiß man, ich...
Alva Anders, na dann.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht bringt das was.
Und die können das aber auch nicht sperren.
Die Sparkasse sagt, sie können das nicht sperren.
Der Überweisungsauftrag, also an wen geht das und welche Höhe das ist,
das stellt nicht das Sicherungsverfahren sicher,
sondern das müssen sie, das müssen die Kunden machen.
Wenn jetzt ein Kunde die Transaktionsdetails nicht ordnungsgemäß vergleicht,
nicht ordnungsgemäß kontrolliert,
dann gilt das als grob fahrlässig
und dementsprechend wäre dann der Kunde in die Pflicht zu nehmen.
Bedeutet, wir sind selber schuld, weil wir einfach nicht genug aufgepasst haben.
Ja, ist ja auch so.
Ja gut, das ist halt wirklich so.
Es ist natürlich blöd, dass es da keine bessere Unterstützung gibt,
dass es da nicht...
Es aber Sicherungsmechanismen gibt, die man aktivieren könnte.
Aber ja, prinzipiell bist du selber schuld.
Aber immerhin konnten wir den Ermittlern eine IBAN und den Namen des Empfängers liefern.
Das muss doch für irgendwas gut sein.
Die wichtigste Information ist die IBAN für uns, denn die ist auf jeden Fall echt.
Der Name muss nicht echt sein.
Sie könnten auch einfach Mickey Mouse eintragen.
Die Bank prüft das nicht unbedingt mehr.
Deswegen ist der Kontoeröffner.
Um das gleichzusetzen mit dem Empfänger.
Der Name kann wiederum uns aber einen Hinweis darauf geben,
ob es woanders im Bundesgebiet vergleichbare Taten mit demselben Namen gibt.
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das Konto, dass es das wirklich gibt
und es den Empfänger auch wirklich gibt, dass es irgend...
Wollte ich gerade sagen, weil es der Chat auch gerade schreibt,
dass es irgendjemand ist, der von seinem Glück gar nichts weiß.
Auch irgendein unbeteiligter Typ.
Ja, zu Hause rufe ich aus purer Verzweiflung nochmal die Notfallhotline an.
Vielleicht hätte ich das auch noch mal.
Vielleicht hätte ich das auch noch mal. Vielleicht hätte ich das auch noch mal.
Das helfen ja meine neuen Informationen über den Betrüger.
Geld kann ja eigentlich gar nicht so schnell aus einem Konto sein.
Wenn man das jetzt ganz schnell irgendwie macht, dann habe ich gedacht vielleicht einen Staus.
Wie hat er es denn überwiesen?
Hatte das per Echtzeitüberweisung gemacht?
Wahrscheinlich.
Das weiß ich natürlich nicht so genau, aber ich meine, du wirst schon wissen,
was er da getan hat, oder?
Ah, das steht da auch.
Echtzeitüberweisung, ja.
Ah, okay.
Dann gibt es keine Chance mehr.
Also das heißt Echtzeitüberweisung, weil tatsächlich das Geld ist innerhalb se amo Zeekunden.
Wenn sowas öfters passiert...
Ja, und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass solche Scams wirklich öfters passieren.
Warum gibt es nicht eine Sicherungsmöglichkeit, dass man sagt, hey, bitte alle Überweisungen eine Stunde verzögern.
Ich meine, so eine Option, da muss doch schon mal einer dran gedacht haben, oder?
Warum macht man das nicht? Das soll doch technisch überhaupt kein Problem sein in der Umsetzung.
Die Sicherung kannst du mit der TAN auch wieder aktivieren.
Ja, da muss man sich halt was anderes überlegen für.
Ja, da gibt es sicherlich Möglichkeiten, dass man das nicht so einfach machen kann.
Das wäre doch tatsächlich eine, da muss man irgendwie, man kann garantiert, wenn man technisch gewillt ist, dort den Riegel vorschieben.
Man könnte zum Beispiel auch gucken, ist die IP, von der sich eingeloggt wird und von dem die Überweisung ausgeht,
die Clive, wobei das...
Das ist die gleiche, weil die TAN abgefragt wurde. Das hätte in dem Fall nichts gebracht.
Naja, also wenn der Kunde das aktiviert, dann soll er nicht motzen.
Also ich denke, man könnte da durchaus was machen.
Bei dem Kollegen quasi, oder?
Also das dauert eher so 20 bis 30 Sekunden, dann ist das auf dem anderen Konto.
Aber das macht ja auch eigentlich überhaupt gar keinen Sinn, dass es das überhaupt gibt.
Doch, doch klar.
Warum soll das keinen Sinn machen?
Was meint ihr, warum die Leute PayPal verwenden?
Das ist halt schnell da.
Wer profitiert von sowas?
Also wenn Sie so direkt fragen, dann kann ich Ihnen auch direkt sagen, ja, das ist ein gutes Mittel für Betrüger.
Wir als Polizei könnten vielleicht sagen, wir wünschen uns, dass das abgeschaltet wird.
Nee.
Aber da wird ja keiner von uns hören.
Die andere Seite der Medaille ist, dass Kunden, die in der digitalen Welt leben und auch damit arbeiten, genau nach diesen Prozessen rufen.
Wie kann es sein, dass eine Online-Überweisung zwei, drei Tage gedauert hat?
Verstehe ich auch.
Und ich will doch, wenn ich online mache, will ich doch, dass das Geld...
Ich will, ich will, dass im Zweifelsfall...
Ich das überweise und der andere es direkt zieht und den Kram losschickt.
Ich will da keine drei Tage warten oder so.
Was soll das?
Wir sind im Jahr 2022.
...sofort da ist.
Also es ist vielleicht auch ein Stück weit Fluch und Segen zugleich.
Für mich fühlt es sich gerade ganz klar wie ein Fluch an.
Quatsch.
Und den muss ich...
Nein, nur weil er...
Das ist im Jahr 2022 schon wichtig, dass es sowas wie Sofortüberweisung gibt.
Ansonsten verwenden die Leute halt PayPal.
Wäre der Typ über PayPal gescampt worden, hätte er nicht mal irgendeinen, wo er anrufen kann.
Irgendwie brechen.
Mit den Bankdaten des Betrügers recherchiere ich weiter.
So, also Alva Andres steht hier jetzt.
Der hat auch eine IBAN und eine BIC.
Ich wette mit euch, dass es irgendeinen Typ, der auch gescampt wurde.
Den gibt's und der wurde auch gescampt.
Und ich google jetzt mal, was das für eine Bank ist.
Das ist die GLS Bank.
Zentrale Service Nummer, die hat natürlich nicht offen, die zentrale Service Nummer.
Fragen und Antworten hat auch nicht offen.
Karten, Sperren.
Weil am Wochenende hier nur Computer zu erreichen sind,
und ich wirklich verzweifelt bin, fällt mir nur noch eine letzte Rette ein.
So hat sich ein Computer an, Leute.
Ich mach das jetzt mal. Ich lass jetzt mal den Account von dem sperren.
But wouldn't they ask for some information, birthday or something like that?
Wahrscheinlich.
Es ist halt unglaublich, dass es da jetzt...
Sprechen Sie bitte jetzt. Sprechen Sie bitte jetzt. Sprechen Sie bitte jetzt.
Bitte nennen Sie den Namen und die Anschrift des Karteninhabers.
Scheiße.
Anschrift.
Alva Andres.
Bahnhofsstraße 3.
2, 5, 4.
4, 2, 1, Kinneberg.
Das ist natürlich klar. Ich meine, das wäre ja auch Wahnsinn, wenn wir jetzt einfach...
Ihre Kartensperre habe ich weitergeleitet.
Wir müssen jetzt mal... Ich habe jetzt gerade sein Konto gesperrt anscheinend.
Na ja, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Wobei, ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das funktioniert.
Irgendwie. Was natürlich auch Wahnsinn ist, dass ich sein Konto sperren kann.
Keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt irgendwas gebracht hat.
Ich hoffe, damit habe ich jetzt nicht der Polizei irgendwie reingefuscht.
Aber zumindest kann er dann erstmal jetzt nichts machen.
Hoffe ich.
Die Sperrhotline.
Die sperrt im Grundsatz ja keine Konten, sondern die sperrt im Zweifelsfall nur Bankkarten.
Aber das Konto an sich gegen Verfügung könnte man damit nicht sperren.
Das hätte ich also auch lassen können.
Da ich bei der GLS-Bank aber telefonisch niemanden erreiche, schreibe ich eine E-Mail.
Jetzt sollte da ja eigentlich denen daran gelegen sein, diesen Betrüger aufzuspüren.
Weil die wollen ja eigentlich auch keinen Betrüger bei sich bei der Bank haben.
Das ist denen wahrscheinlich wurscht.
Was können die machen?
Mal ganz davon abgesehen.
Denn der Typ kann denen ja auch vieles erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Also darauf zu reagieren, das ist halt auch schwierig.
Jetzt für die Bank das nachzuvollziehen.
Ich meine, du kannst viel sagen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Das Geld ist schon weg.
Die GLS-Bank ist eine Direktbank.
Kontoeröffnungen funktionieren hier komplett online.
Da benze, danke schön für den Zap.
Mit einem digitalen Identifikationsverfahren.
Die GLS macht das nicht selbst, sondern nutzt einen Service der Deutschen Post.
Was ist das?
Ein Videocall, bei dem Ausweisdaten abgefragt und überprüft werden.
Laut Experten ein sehr sicheres Verfahren.
Oder ist beim Betrüger Alva Andres etwas schiefgelaufen?
Ich frage nach, bei Christoph Wolf von der GLS-Bank.
Er hat sich das Identifikationsvideo von Alva Andres noch einmal angeschaut.
Also ich hätte keine Auffälligkeiten festgestellt.
Das Bild auf dem Ausweis, was da war mit der auftretenden Person, kommt ihm sehr nahe.
Wesentliche Merkmale wie Nase, Gesichtszüge, Ohrenstellung, Augenstellung, Augenhöhlen.
Das war identisch oder nahezu identisch.
Können Sie mir Informationen über diesen Menschen geben?
Leider nicht.
Da laufen zurzeit Ermittlungsverfahren.
Da kann ich jetzt keine Auskunft zu geben.
Also einmal schon nicht aus ermittlungstaktischen Gründen, aber auch nicht aufgrund des Bankgeheimnisses.
Irgendwie schade.
Aber vermutlich ohnehin keine echte Spur.
Denn professionelle Betrüger eröffnen die verwendeten Konten eigentlich nie selbst.
Sie können entweder Anzeigen schreiben.
Sag ich doch, das ist wahrscheinlich auch irgendein Typ, der gescampt wurde.
... und darüber Leute gewinnen, die das Konto für Sie erstellen.
In dem Glauben, etwas Gutes zu tun.
Beispielsweise bei einer Marktforschungsumfrage teilzunehmen.
Wie gut eröffnet sich das Konto bei Bank X.
Oder Sie kaufen sowas, beispielsweise auch im, ich nenne es jetzt mal Gartner.
Geil.
Das ist ein Pfeifettscammer.
Kurz gesagt, das Geld ist immer noch weg.
Und der Täter immer noch unbekannt.
Und als ob das nicht alles schon ärgerlich genug wäre, haben wir noch ein Problem.
Obwohl es eigentlich eher ein Grund zur Freude sein sollte.
Am Montagmorgen um 6 Uhr fliegen wir in den Urlaub.
Zu den Eltern meiner Frau nach Kalifornien, wo wir nur schwer zu erreichen sind für GLS
Bank, Haspa und die Polizei.
Doch einen Versuch starten wir noch, jetzt wo am Montag alle Büros wieder besetzt sind.
Wir sind jetzt hier in Amsterdam am Flughafen.
Und es ist kurz vor halb neun.
Und ab halb neun kann ich anrufen bei dieser Hotline.
Und um kurz vor neun ist Boarding.
Das heißt, ich bin jetzt hier.
Ja, die Dame der GLS Bank war sehr, sehr nett am Telefon, hat das jetzt alles aufgenommen.
Und sie sagte auch, ja, meistens gefälschte Konten und das haben sie dauernd.
Und sie sagt auch, man fällt dauernd auf sowas rein.
Das ist ja Wahnsinn, da muss man ja irgendwie mal ein System hinterkriegen, wie man das verhindern
kann, oder?
Das denke ich mir auch.
Oder das Wichtigste, meiner Meinung nach, ist wirklich die Aufklärung der Bevölkerung.
Die Beantwortung.
Du bist selbstverständlich, du bist selbst dafür da.
Du bist selbst dafür verantwortlich.
Ja, also das Erste ist, lass dich nicht scammen.
Aber ich denke schon, dass man da auch aus Bank Sicht was dagegen machen könnte, wenn
man gewillt ist.
Also ich meine, was spricht denn dagegen zum Beispiel, dass man kann man sofort Überweisung
deaktivieren oder dass man irgendwas da müssen wir halt mal freifertig sich was überlegen.
Ich meine, solche Scams, wenn, wenn, wenn, wenn solche Scams System haben, da sieht man
ja.
Ich meine, wenn das nicht nach dem gleichen Muster funktioniert, dann sieht man ja, worauf
die basieren und dann, dass man sich da irgendwas dagegen ausdenkt.
Kannst du und dieses Misstrauen, dieses grundsätzlich kritisch sein, das kann, das können wir als
hassbar den Kunden nicht nehmen und man muss tatsächlich auch sagen, doch, du kannst das
schon tracken.
Aber woher willst du wissen?
Aber woher willst du wissen, ob das jetzt der Kunde ist oder nicht?
Also ich meine, wo die TAN eingegeben wurde?
Ja, kannst du.
Aber du weißt doch nicht, ob der Kunde die TAN eingegeben hat oder der Scammer.
Das kannst du doch nicht wissen.
Ich meine, was du machen kannst, ist also was du machen kannst, ist sowas so eine so eine.
Ja, sagen wir so eine 70 80 % Geschichte.
Login und TAN IP unterscheiden sich nicht.
Die haben das Passwort über eine Seite abgefischt, haben sich damit eingeloggt und dann übers
Handy.
Das ist ja der Witz bei dem Scam.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist die gleiche Login und Überweisung ist die gleiche.
Aber was du machen könntest, ist, du könntest zum Beispiel richtig sowas hier in der Richtung.
Das dachte ich mir auch.
Du könntest zum Beispiel so ein 70 80 % Ding machen, wie das beispielsweise Amazon auch
macht oder PayPal macht.
So nach dem Motto hier.
Man guckt, von welcher IP loggen sich die Leute normalerweise?
Ein.
Und dann machst du einen Geo Lookup, aus welcher Region loggen sich die Leute meistens ein?
Und wenn, wenn du dich quasi zu, sagen wir mal 70 % von einer IP aus dem Großraum Frankfurt
am Main einloggen und auf einmal logst du dich ein aus Shanghai.
Dass du dann nochmal eine extra Sicherheitsfrage beantworten musst zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Das könnte man durchaus machen und wäre wahrscheinlich auch sinnvoll.
Ja, sowas.
Ja.
Also es gäbe.
Ich denke, wenn man gewillt ist, da was zu machen, was eigentlich Banken ein gewisses
Interesse haben sollten, sich da auch hervorzutun versus PayPal und sowas.
Ja, aber es ist trotzdem nochmal ein extra eine extra Hürde.
Und dass du dann ein VPN kriegst, dass du dann direkt eine IP aus der Region des eigentlichen
Besitzers hast.
Also so einfach aus dem Ärmel schüttelst du das auch nicht.
Frankfurt ist jetzt easy.
Frankfurt ist easy.
Frankfurt hast du genug VPN Anbieter.
Aber wenn du irgendeinen Kunden hast, der was weiß ich aus irgendwie Region, was weiß
ich, Nieder, Niederaffenhausen oder so sich einloggt und das ungefähr zuordnen kannst,
damit VPN zu finden.
Wahrscheinlich nicht so einfach.
Also VPN IPs kannst du nicht erkennen.
VPN IPs kannst du nicht erkennen.
VPN IPs kannst du nur erkennen, wenn VPN Anbieter quasi die gleichen Ranges verwenden und
du reproduzierbar feststellen kannst.
Ah, das ist ein VPN.
Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel du einen VPN aufbaust zu mir, wird das nie jemand erkennen,
dass du da über einen VPN meinen Internetanschluss verwendest oder so.
Also ich denke, man könnte durchaus mehr machen, dass solche Scams schwieriger werden.
Und für die Leute, die das aufregt, könntest du einfach eine Option einbauen.
Ja, ich möchte das ausschalten.
Und dann schaltest du es halt aus, wenn du es nicht willst.
Aber dann darfst du dich auch nicht mal beschweren, gescampt zu werden.
Schuld liegt schon auch ein Stück weit bei ihnen jetzt.
Natürlich.
Im Flüge haben wir ausgiebig Zeit, über unsere Fehler nachzudenken und uns zu ärgern.
Über den Betrüger, die Banken, aber vor allem uns selbst.
Doch dann...
Ja, selbst schuld.
Wir sind gerade in L.A. gelandet.
Auf jeden Fall zum großen Teil selbst schuld dran.
Aber trotzdem, dass nicht wenigstens mal eine Hotline erreichbar ist am Wochenende, wobei
war ja anscheinend.
Ja.
Oder auch nicht.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Stundenflug.
Ich bin ziemlich fertig.
Und habe gerade eine E-Mail bekommen, dass anscheinend das Bankkonto gesperrt werden
konnte.
Ich kann Ihnen aber auch schon sagen, dass wir dem auf die Schliche gekommen sind und
auf die Gelder schon eingefroren haben.
Aha.
Wow.
Der Kunde hat relativ viel versucht, mit Echtzeitüberweisungen zu arbeiten, was natürlich viele Betrüger
zunutze machen, wo sie innerhalb von drei Sekunden das Geld bei der Empfängerbank europaweit
gutgeschrieben wird.
Und dann ist das weg.
Sie haben keine Chance, das zu stoppen.
Und das ist halt ein Thema, wo unser System merkt, aha, der macht jetzt vielleicht mehr
Echtzeitüberweisungen.
Das ist doch sowas.
Das ist zum Beispiel eine gute Sache.
Du checkst einfach, so nach dem Motto, kein normaler Kunde macht 50 Echtzeitüberweisungen
in 15 Minuten.
Da stimmt doch was nicht.
Oder auch in anderen Ländern, die nicht so üblich sind, und stoppt die auch.
Wir können Ihnen die 3.333 Euro auch zurücküberweisen.
Krass.
Die volle Summe.
Das ist überraschend und extrem.
Das ist natürlich für uns hervorragend, und da haben wir richtig Glück gehabt.
Und es gibt wohl noch jemanden, der 8.000 Euro überwiesen hat, und der kriegt sie auch
zurück.
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt noch ein paar Formalitäten erledigen, aber dann ist das
Geld wieder da.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich das beste Urlaubsgeschenk, was man irgendwie kriegen kann.
3.333 Euro und 33 Cent zurück.
Naja.
Eine Achterbahn.
Oh Mann.
Ja.
Also, Ende gut, alles gut?
Also, du bist ja nicht von minus 3.000, sondern du bist wieder auf Null.
Aktuell, das hier war ja jetzt ja quasi...
30 Euro und 33 Cent.
Einfach ca.
7.000 Euro gerade, was sie gezeigt haben.
Zurück.
Was keinen Sinn ergibt, aber okay.
Eine Achterbahn.
Oh Mann ey.
Das kann er sich einfach...
Also...
Das kann er sich nochmal scammen lassen.
Das Geld ist ja wieder da.
Das Ende gut, alles gut?
Nicht ganz.
Das Geld ist ja wieder da.
Das Ende gut, alles gut?
Nicht ganz.
Oh Mann ey.
Moment, Moment.
Das ist ja auch kein Geld.
Das war ja alles kurz.
Das war alles kurz.
So.
Ich war genauso wütend, mich mit dem Geld zu gefordert.
Und dann, was war mehr?
Hm.
Genau.
Und dann war das eine gute Sache.
Das war ja auch ein sehr gutes Motto.
So.
Ja, also, das geht schon.
Die war ja ruhig.
Und dann kam der nossa.
Warte, warte.
Ja.
Warte.
Er hat ja schon mit mir gesprochen.
Das war so wahnsinnig.
Wir haben auch mit den Leuten gehofft, dass er nicht durchgegangen wäre.
Wer hat aber nicht gehofft.
werden und diese Echtzeitüberweisung macht es ihnen natürlich was daran bedenklich ist weiß
ich auch nicht weil ich meine du kannst ja wohl kannst ja wohl kaum von scammern erwarten dass
du sich dumm anstellen also wäre gut ja dürfen Banken die trotzdem anbieten ja das dürfen klar
warum nicht Kunden da ja ein Stück weit nach verlangen ja das also du kannst du kannst doch
nicht alles jetzt irgendwie sperren nur weil man damit was scammen kann in so einer schnelllebigen
Zeit wie wir heute leben ich persönlich sehe die immer noch kritisch aber natürlich haben
die eine Berechtigung aber wahrscheinlich können das auch deaktivieren für sein Konto und um das
zu stoppen müssen glaube ich Bankalgorithmen noch besser werden und wir Kunden richtig natürlich
noch auf das ist das ist das ist gut dass er das sagt weil letztendlich musst du selbst gucken dass
du nicht gescampt wirst um sowas zu verhindern und jetzt interessiert uns natürlich noch eure
Meinung seid ihr schon mal auf Fishing reingefallen wie kann man sich schützen
wie kann man sich schützen wie kann man sich schützen
was fordert ihr vielleicht auch von den Banken damit das alles noch sicherer wird
schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare und folgt uns und liked uns ja das ist keine echte Person da kann
die Polizei wohl nichts machen wobei das nicht unbedingt heißen muss keine Ahnung ehrlich gesagt
aber ich denke nicht dass es heißen muss dass das jetzt alles eingestellt also dass das alles
abgebrochen wird sondern diese eine Sache gegen diese nicht existierte Person dass man als weiter
guckt wer dahinter steckt das ist ja wieder was anderes könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen dass
das passiert auf der anderen Seite die haben so viel auf dem Tisch
vielleicht sind die froh so nach dem Motto ja hat sich erledigt bämm weg damit das das Bildmaterial
ist eh zusammengefakt in dem Beitrag ich glaube da ging es eher um die eigentliche Aussage und
dass man das irgendwie nachstellt also ich glaube nichts von dem Bildmaterial was man da gesehen
hat war irgendwie wirklich echt ja also von diesen wie schockiert sie waren und so das war wahrscheinlich
alles gefakt weil ganz ehrlich wenn ich schockiert bin das letzte was mir einfällt ist erstmal meine
Handykamera zurück und sagen nehme ich mal kurz auf dabei wie ich schockiert bin
Gut, vielleicht, wenn du beim NDR arbeitest, ist das vielleicht so.
Also ich musste mein Scalable-Depot auch eröffnen mit PostIdent.
Und dafür musste ich mir sogar einen temporären neuen Personalausweis holen.
Und nachdem ich in Hanau nicht rangekommen bin, bin ich in eine der Nachbargemeinden gegangen und hab das bei denen gemacht.
Wie, das geht nicht?
Wenn da einer durchs Bild läuft?
Das ist ja fast wie bei irgendeinem Microsoft-Zertifikat.
Ist natürlich auch sehr sinnvoll, wenn du es dann einfach nochmal machen könntest.
So, was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten hier?
MacBook Fix.
Okay, wir gucken uns mal schnell den MacBook Fix in Zeitraffer an.
Das ist ziemlich im Arsch, oder?
Monarch S USB-Port.
Wobei, es ist ja kein...
Es ist ja kein...
Nur das hier ist ja USB.
Das hier ist...
Das hier sind...
Was ist denn das hier?
Lightning?
Was ist denn das, Chat?
Irgendjemand im Plan?
Ist das Display-Port?
Mini-Display-Port, oder?
Firewire?
Quatsch.
Das ist doch kein Firewire mehr.
Thunderbolt?
Okay.
Was?
Nein.
Was, wirklich?
Thunderbolt 2?
Tatsächlich, Thunderbolt 2.
Alles klar.
Das hat aber ordentlich gelitten.
Der Audio-Port, Mann.
Das ist klar.
Das Display ist eine verlassener Reise.
Ganz klar, das gesamte Panel ist verschritten.
Also, das hat schon ordentlich eingesteckt.
Hat das einer aus dem Fenster geschmissen,
oder ist mit dem Reifen drüber gefahren, oder so?
Es kann ein kostliches Anliegen sein.
Aber ich wollte surechnen, dass das Logica-Bord
sehr wenig funktionell ist,
bevor ich irgendwelche Teile kaufe.
Anscheinend von der horrifischen Form des Chassis
und dem substantialen Bende,
scheint das Hauptgerät keine Korrosion
oder Signale von Schäden zu haben.
Nur um es zu richtigstellen...
Oder hat sich da ein besonders Pipo-Fett-Person draufgesetzt?
Meine Frage, Chad, ist da eine SSD drin, die man ausbaut?
Weil ansonsten würde ich mein altes MacBook im Leben nicht über Ebay verkaufen,
wenn da noch eine unverschlüsselte Festplatte drin ist, die mit Daten von mir...
Das kommt noch? Okay.
Paulaner, danke schön für den Zap.
Fuck.
Oh!
Aha, kommt zu mir.
Wollte grad sagen, einfach das MacBook-Sofa benutzen, wer braucht denn schon ein Gehäuse?
Was ist das denn? Quad-Core 7? Von wann sind denn die Dinger?
Das ist auch schon ein paar Jährchen alt, oder?
2014, ja.
Erst mal Minecraft mit dem Tablet.
What exactly we need to make this fully functional once again?
After a word from today's sponsor, Private Internet Access.
If you want to enjoy all the benefits of Private Internet Access,
use the link in the description below to grab an impressive 82% discount.
First of all, the good parts.
The logic board, fans, speakers, battery and trackpad can be used again.
While I would love to simply try and bend the warped casing back into shape,
lining it up with a new bottom casing would be next to impossible.
If it came with the original bottom casing,
I might have been able to bend them both back at the same time.
I will need to source a new top casing.
These regularly come with a keyboard as well.
I found one here on eBay.
It looks a bit dirty, but much straighter than the one we've got.
Man kann MacBook-Gehäuse kaufen?
The one we've currently got.
I also found a bottom casing pretty cheap as well.
This just leaves the screen.
It took me quite a while to find one for a decent price.
And sellers regularly wanted over 400 Australian dollars just for the screen.
Klar, warum nicht?
Naja, weil da in der Regel ein Notebook dazugehört.
Warum bauen die Leute das aus und verkaufen dann das Gehäuse?
...for 200 Australian dollars.
They were selling it as four parts without any guarantee,
however they did mention that the display was in great shape.
After a week or so, all of the parts had arrived.
First of all, I opened up the bottom casing,
packaged well enough in some bubble wrap.
It wasn't overly clean,
but it's nothing a little bit of elbow grease can't fix.
The scratching was fairly minor,
and all of the rubber feet were present.
Next up was the new top casing, also from eBay.
Thankfully, it was wrapped in bubble wrap.
I've received laptops where the seller hasn't even gone that far.
It looks to be pretty straight.
And as far as I know, all of the keys should be working as well.
So viel Poggas Bubble Wrap.
One of the little rubber seals for the heat sink was missing.
And the other one was close to falling off.
It's pretty clear that no attempts to remove dust had been made.
But thankfully, I like cleaning computers.
The real test is seeing whether both halves slot together.
The tolerances are super tight and...
guys, did any of you guys ever open a Shield TV?
That just caught my eye...
Lately my Shield TV has had loud fan noises,
lately my Shield TV has had loud fan noises,
I think i have to clean it up.
I don't know if I can open it without that the screen falling apart.
that I have to clean it without that the screen falling apart.
...totally it is a good fit.
The last package to open is the 4-parts 2014 MacBook Pro
which I bought as the whole machine was cheaper than Dear, are you gonna laugh?
Patrick, you're going to laugh out loud.
I thought this would be all,
just to buy a new one.
But I said no!
nicht einfach sinnlos Geld ausgeben.
Das war das Erste, das war mein allererster Gedanke.
Ich kaufe ein neues.
Nicht der Fernseher macht Geräusche,
die Android-TV-Box daneben
macht Geräusche.
Wie in New York.
Das ist meistens
kein allzu gutes Zeichen dafür.
Warum er noch eins hat?
Ja, er hat sich ein Gehäuse gekauft,
oben und unten, und jetzt hat er sich noch
ein neues MacBook gekauft,
mit Display.
Also, im Prinzip hat er jetzt
zweieinhalb
oder ein Dreiviertel-Macbook.
Oder
zwei
ein Viertel eher, weil er hat zwei Boards
und er hat zwei Gehäuse.
Er hat zwei Displays, wovon eins kaputt ist.
Er repariert
das Notebook jetzt, indem er sich ein neues Notebook
kauft, korrekt.
Mit 16 GB RAM und
einem 2 GB NVIDIA 750M
Grafikprozessor. Und diese Langheit ist
wegen der Batterie
gar nicht zu steuern.
Das macht den Mac zu...
Moment! Eigentlich können wir aufhören, das Video zu gucken, weil wir wissen doch jetzt schon, was passiert.
Der hat ein neues Gehäuse, der hat noch...
Okay, wie redet er... wie redet er... der ist, ähm...
Wobei, wait a minute.
Der baut jetzt...
Der hat doch ein funktionierendes Notebook, was will
er eigentlich jetzt?
Also, ich mein, der will ja wohl
kaum das... der will ja wohl kaum den Bildschirm
abmachen vom Funktionierenden, oder?
Also, wozu?
Das auch noch besser in der
Nachfäre hat, ja?
Sieht da irgendeinem Widerstand aus, oder?
Oder was ist das? Keine Ahnung.
Konnexatoren, okay.
Erstmal richtig schön Flux drauf spritzen.
Das sieht fast aus als hängt das hier zusammen.
Sauler Sucker, genau.
Vor allem, wie hat er das denn hingekriegt, das so zu verkacken?
Ich mein, der hat sogar richtig schönen Flux.
Zeug da drauf gehabt, da muss der eigentlich fast nichts machen, außer es dranhalten
und es fließt an die richtige Stelle.
Siehst du, da ist gut, wenn man so eine Druckluftdose hat.
Das ist gut, wenn man so eine Druckluftdose hat.
Auch wenn er da nicht richtig ist, muss er trotzdem gut sein, um das hier so zu verkacken.
Der hat schon 3 ein Drittel Notebooks daheim.
Das ist der neue Bade.
Okay, jetzt hat er schon 3 ein Drittel Notebooks daheim.
Jetzt hat er schon 3 ein Drittel Notebooks daheim.
This includes the trackpad, which I'm hoping is undamaged.
The old casing was pretty bent, meaning the trackpad wouldn't click.
And here's hoping the mechanism isn't damaged.
These cost about 50$ secondhand on eBay.
I'm also taking out these exhaust funnels as surprisingly enough...
Also, der hat, okay nur, weil ich das richtig verstehe, der hat 24$ ausgegeben für das distraute
Mittel.
Das ist einfach schrecklich.
Das ist ein toller Tipp.
Und hat jetzt nochmal 500-600 Dollar ausgegeben für die Ersatzteile, oder wie?
Das ist aber bestimmt sehr... das hat sich bestimmt gelohnt.
Seriously, niemand schraubt sein Notebook auseinander,
um die Fans zu...
... zu cleanen.
Ja, der braucht das kaputte Teil gar nicht, der hätte einfach das neue behalten können,
was auch noch bessere Specs hatte.
Egal, davon kriegst du aber kein YouTube-Video.
Was hat er...
Was hat er applied?
Threadlocker?
Was soll denn das sein?
Schrauben... Schraubenschlosser?
Was? Hä?
Eine Schraubensicherung?
Nicht wahr?
Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
... working replacement battery, I'll simply tape the old one back into the casing.
Kleber.
So, let's see how it turned out.
Und thankfully, the display along with the backlight was...
Wofür braucht man das?
Dass die...
Das ist das, wenn du das Notebook quasi im Auto hast und es vibriert, dass die sich
nicht mit der Zeit lösen, oder wie?
... was working.
The soldering I had to do had definitely set me back in both time and confidence.
Ah, okay.
But so far, so good.
I decided to apply...
Also, wir fassen zusammen, er hat aus einem funktionierenden MacBook ein funktionierendes
MacBook gebaut mit jetzt schlechteren Specs.
Excellent.
... failure and potential issues.
I ran some benchmarks and we'll see how much cooler it ran afterwards.
The paste is very crusty.
It's a good thing I...
Richtige Five-Hat-Aktion.
Okay, das hätten wir uns auch sparen können.
So, was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
The only thing that matters is that you save live, I'm not sure.
Bash scripting will change your life.
Unter life changing machen wir es heute nicht mehr, oder?
Also, normale Sachen, das muss wenn schon life changing sein.
Ich kann dir sagen, was das für eine Musik ist.
Das ist...
1.38.
Das ist Super Smash.
Nee, doch nicht.
Das ist Pokémon.
Du hast recht.
Korrekt.
Ich kann sagen, es hört sich auch nicht so an wie das hier, aber okay.
Ja, das hört sich nämlich schon eher
danach an. So, haben wir noch irgendwas
Spannendes, was wir gucken können?
Was ist das?
8 Minuten.
Fireship.
New World, Death of a Game. Das gucke ich mir jetzt nicht an.
28 Minuten, New World, Alter.
Okay, zeig her.
Bleeding Edge, Tech Stack for
2025.
Also der ist so weit ahead
schon im Kopf.
Der ist so high IQ, der hat schon
seine Webseitentechnik geplant
für 2025, alles klar.
Rails, Leute.
Es ist nicht mehr im Trend.
Ich gebe zu. Rails ist ziemlich
so aus der Mode
gekommen, aber ich mag Rails immer noch.
Aber ich mache nichts mehr mit Rails.
Das ist der Unterschied. Ich mag
Rails, aber ich mache nichts mehr mit
Rails.
Ja, hauptsache mal schön in die Nase rein.
Gefilmt. Beste Kamera-Position immer.
Aber ich mache es jedes paar Jahre, weil ich
den Prozess genieße. Die meiste Kodierung
mache ich mit meinen eigenen Händen, aber das Projekt wird
open source und ich werde wahrscheinlich mit
ein paar anderen Ingenieuren zusammenarbeiten, um das Projekt zu
roundieren. Es ist ein kleiner Team-Effort, was
eine wichtige Vorstellung ist, wenn man den Tech-Stack
wählt, weil viele Technologien mehr
gut für große Teams sind. Software-Ingenieure
lieben zu flexieren. Das Tech-Stack muss
bussen oder drippen. In anderen Worten,
verdächtig überingeniert. Die Realität ist,
dass ich Fireship als WordPress-Blog
bauen kann, ein Membership-Plugin zu geben und
es zu Millionen von Usern zu skalieren.
Wenn ich Geld machen möchte, wäre das...
Aber allein schon, weil es WordPress ist, macht das nicht.
Wer der 2022
noch was auf sich hält
im Frontend-Game
benutzt freiwillig
WordPress. Smart thing to do.
But I want to build something a little more special than
just a WordPress-Blog. In the next version of the site,
courses will have progress tracking
that will also include challenges like quizzes
and interactive demos powered by StackBlitz.
In my experience, the majority of modern
web development happens on the frontend.
That being said, one of the most important decisions
to make is your frontend UI library.
And for that, I have chosen Svelte.
I've built something with pretty much every UI...
Chat! Wir haben doch die richtige Entscheidung
getroffen vor ein paar Monaten, als wir
Svelte gelernt haben.
Wenn sogar Fireship das jetzt macht.
...library on the market. They all have their
pros and cons, but Svelte is the one that feels
most productive to me. And coincidentally,
just yesterday, it debuted at the top of the
most loved web... Battle-Schieb, das habe ich nicht
mitbekommen, ey.
...frameworks on the Stack Overflow 2022,
Survey. I think developers love it for how
natural... Moment, was ist...
Was ist Phoenix?
Irgendjemand schon mal Phoenix benutzt?
Frontend-technisch?
Wo ist Blazor? Ja, Blazor hat's nicht besser
verdient. Ich find's auch interessant, dass
Vue.js mittlerweile so weit unten ist.
Das liegt aber, glaube ich, hauptsächlich
an der Umstellung von Version 2 auf Version 3,
was die Leute
irgendwie ein bisschen verschreckt hat.
Und das
Vue-Ökosystem hat ja bis heute nicht wirklich
abgecatcht.
Mit allem für Version 3.
Stack Overflow 2022.
Wo ist Angular? Tja, irgendwo ganz
hier unten, würde ich sagen.
...22, Survey. I think developers love it
for how natural it makes reactive data
feel. When a mutable variable changes,
the UI reacts. You don't have to jump through
any weird... Ich finde,
Svelte hat... Ich hab das
jetzt ja für einige Sachen schon benutzt und wir haben
es auch im Stream öfters benutzt. Svelte hat
an vielen Stellen
ein bisschen zu viel und an manchen Stellen
ein bisschen zu wenig Magic.
Also, zum Beispiel,
wie was Reactive gemacht wird, ist mir teilweise
zu viel Magic, weil du
gar nicht weißt, wenn es nicht funktioniert,
warum es nicht funktioniert.
Manchmal musst du einfach
irgendwelche Variablen mitcaptchern
lassen, die du gar nicht brauchst,
damit die Reactivity funktioniert
und sowas. Das ist ein bisschen...
Ja, das ist nicht so
einfach, ja.
...the UI reacts. You don't have to jump
through any weird hoops to make things reactive.
Now, the other thing I really like about Svelte is
the way you share data across components,
which is done with stores. Ja, das ist wirklich cool,
dass es eingebaut ist. Das gefällt mir auch.
...anywhere in the application by simply
putting a dollar sign in front of it. This pattern
is actually very similar to the way things are done in Angular.
Leider kann man Stores nicht gescheit
erweitern. Also, du kannst zwar
ein neues Store-Objekt anlegen, aber dann kannst du
nicht auf deine eigenen Sachen zugreifen.
Es ist... Also, ich hoffe, dass
sich da noch ein bisschen was tut.
Angular, MonkaS.
Matrix, Kinua, Spike, da gefällt es.
In my opinion, Angular is awesome and the most
underappreciated framework out there. It's extremely
popular and enterprise for a good reason. Ja, man muss aber sagen,
Chat, ja, es werden täglich neue
JavaScript-Frameworks created. Das ist schon richtig.
Daniel Lull, danke für den
Sub, aber es hat sich die
letzten Jahre über dort erfreulich
wenig getan. Es ist
Angular
View und React
und seit den letzten...
in letzter Zeit ein bisschen vermehrt
zwällt, aber es gibt seit Jahren
eigentlich die Top-3-Frameworks.
React ist einfach
der King, quasi so,
was Verbreitung angeht.
Und View und Angular
irgendwie unten drunter. Ich glaube, Angular,
ja, gerade... Niemand mag Angular,
außer im Enterprise-Umfeld.
Und dann drunter
gibt es da noch ein paar andere, die sich etablieren,
aber es ist nicht mehr so,
dass du jetzt jeden Monat
komplett neue Tools lernen musst.
Gibt es zwar immer noch,
aber ist dann erstmal nicht so wild.
... but in 2022,
React is definitely still the most popular UI library.
React, genau. Das ist halt wirklich...
Also React haut da halt alles...
Ja, es wählt, guckt da unten.
... sind wir hier.
... ecosystem of supporting libraries.
I think that's the most compelling argument to use it.
When it comes down to the UI library itself,
there are cleaner options out there, like SolidJS,
that would also provide better performance.
I also seriously considered View,
which is not only a great framework, but also has
a large number of supporting libraries as well.
But the more important decision is, which meta-framework
do you want to use? React has Next,
View has Nuxt, Angular has Universal,
and Svelte has Kit.
Most applications out there need some form of server-side
rendering to make their sites visible to
search engines and bots. Svelte Kit
is the official SSR solution that's being worked
on by Rich Harris, but as of today,
it's still in beta. Using a framework that's
not at a stable release is kind of risky.
You could pour a ton of work into an app, then the framework
developers decide to pull a feature on the final
release that torpedoes your entire business.
Not very likely. Und die ändern
auch öfters mal Sachen ins Svelte Kit.
Also da kann's schon mal sein, dass du dich dann wundert,
so hm, warum funktioniert das nicht? Und dann stellst du fest,
ah nee, die Hooks müssen jetzt an einen
anderen Ort und sowas.
Ich kann's auch nicht machen, wenn ich das neu verbauen werde.
Der zweite Framework, den ich sagen würde, ist
Next.js. Next.js ist bereits ein
tolles Framework, aber es hat auch eine Menge cooles
und cooles, wie genannte Routing und so.
Ich habe auch letztens ein Video gemacht über
Nuxt, ein weiteres tolles Framework, das ich
hoffentlich in Zukunft auch einen vollen Kurs machen werde.
Aber welche Major-Version? Die sind noch gar nicht.
Svelte Kit ist
Version 387 oder so.
Aber es ist immer noch
pre-released
Version, also die sind noch gar nicht
nirgendswo.
Das neue Signal, das stimmt schon. Gerade beim
Umstieg von Svelte 2 auf 3,
da hat sich in einem Punkt
so viel getan. Früher war ja quasi
Options API das Ding der Wahl,
was viele Leute an Vue auch mochten.
Die geht ja immer noch, aber
die coolen Leute machen jetzt,
wie heißt die neue,
wie heißt das nochmal bei Vue?
Nicht Options API,
sondern,
ich hab vergessen, wie sie das nennen,
ähm,
Composition, genau.
Ja, Composition, genau.
Du kannst zwar beides noch nehmen, aber wenn
du dir die offiziellen Beispiele anguckst,
dementsprechend kannst du eigentlich alles vergessen,
was du dir bei Vue 2
anguckst, wenn du es
quasi im Vue 3
Sinn machen solltest.
Aber welche sollte man jetzt
lernen, wenn man genau eins wählen kann?
Tja, das ist die
Frage der Fragen im
JavaScript Frontend
Dschungel.
Kann man so nicht sagen.
Von der Verbreitung her müsste es eigentlich React sein,
aber ich persönlich bin kein großer Fan von React.
Wahrscheinlich Vue.
Ich find Vue zum Einstieg eigentlich immer noch
am nettesten.
In letzter Zeit mach ich aber vermehrt
SvelteKit.
Also mit Quick hab ich mich noch nie beschäftigt,
aber wundert mich nicht, dass es da nicht schon 30.000 neue Sachen gibt.
Es gibt auch noch
Replayable Applications,
aber auch das ist für mich ein bisschen zu blutig.
Wenn es um Server-Rendering geht,
brauchst du keine Meta-Framework,
wie zum Beispiel
Javascript-Library.
Dann eher nicht.
Ansonsten brauchst du eine Full-Stack-Framework
wie Ruby on Rails, Laravel, Django
oder was auch immer, um all deine Inhalte
auf dem Server zu rendern.
Diese Frameworks haben Vorteile für bestimmte
Applikationen, aber in meinem Fall ist Full-Blown Server-Rendering
wichtig, weil die Inhalte auf der echten Seite
nicht so oft verändert werden.
Es ist viel einfacher, die gesamte Seite zu prerendern,
zu einem Storage-Bucket zu uploaden und dann
auf einer CDN zu cachen.
Wenn du dann einen dedicateden Server hast, musst du dann
überlegen, wie man es mit entweder serverlosen Funktionen
oder, wenn du einen wirklich komplizierten Tech-Stack
wie Kubernetes willst, mit einem
sehr komplizierten Text-Stack machen.
Also man kann es auch für eine einzelne Webseite
wirklich übertreiben.
Ich meine, für eine einzelne Webseite mit
ich meine, das ist im Prinzip eine relativ statische
Webseite mit irgendwelchen
Kursen
drinnen. Das ist jetzt nett,
dass das irgendwie neuer
was weiß ich, irgendwie
super interaktiver, dynamischer
Content-Gedöns wäre.
Man muss es nicht übertreiben, da brauchst du keinen
Kubernetes-Cluster für, um das Ding laufen zu lassen.
Ich sacke komplett,
was CSS angeht.
Also ich kann das überhaupt nicht gut.
Ich hab da auch keinen Plan von.
Allerdings muss ich sagen, ich komm mit Tailwind ganz
gut klar,
weil ich dann mir zum größten
Teil auch keine Farben und sowas ausdenken
muss, sondern einfach die vorgefertigten verwende
und gut ist.
Das heißt, ein Tool, das CSS
...
Ja, Tailwind, Tailwind find ich auch gut.
Das schützt
dich natürlich nicht davor, trotzdem ein bisschen
CSS lernen zu müssen, weil
das ist nicht so wie irgendwelche CSS-Frameworks,
so keine Ahnung, was gibt's denn da irgendwie
von Bootstrap
bis Material Design und sonst was.
Die designen das halt für dich.
Bei Tailwind musst du halt die Klassen dran schreiben,
was dann das CSS generiert, wie es
aussehen soll. Das ist im Prinzip immer noch CSS.
Aber ich find's
trotzdem angenehmer.
Doch, es gibt Leute, die mögen CSS.
Es gibt relativ große Channels auf YouTube,
die kümmern sich nur um CSS und haben
irgendwie 500.000 plus Abos.
Ich weiß zwar auch nicht, wie man so krass
CSS-Fanboyen kann, aber das gibt's.
Ja, ich mag Tailwind auch.
Naja, wenn du selbst CSS schreibst, musst du's
nix purgen, weil du ja so nur reinschreibst, was du brauchst.
Es sei denn, du fügst 50 Klassen ein, die du
dann nicht verwendest, was aber merkwürdig wär.
Jawoll, oldschool Bootstrap.
Das hab ich ausprobiert, hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Ich weiß nicht wirklich gut über
JavaScript und CSS Bescheid.
Ich weiß Bescheid genug, dass ich
Web-Apps machen kann,
aber wirklich, ich würd nicht sagen, dass ich da
grad... also JavaScript denke
ich kann ich mittlerweile wirklich ganz brauchbar,
aber CSS gar nicht.
Leute, seriously?
Jetzt kommt der Boomer,
ehemaliger
hauptberuflicher Linux-Administrator
durch bei mir.
Ich mag das
immer noch,
irgendeine Cloud-VM zu haben mit
simplem Backend.
Scheiß auf
diesen ganzen Krempel.
Minimaler API-Backend
und dann Frontend und gut ist
eigene VM.
Linux drauf.
Backend gestartet,
gut ist.
Da kannst du auch
komplett machen, was du willst und bist nicht
darauf angewiesen, was da mitgeliefert wird.
Mit
User-Auth, ich mache selten
was mit User-Auth, weil
wenn überhaupt sind das irgendwelche Seiten,
die public oder nur, also entweder
public mit
also keinem irgendwie
userspezifischen
Sachen oder irgendwas internes.
Also, ich weiß nicht,
ich bin ja, ich weiß,
dass es das gibt und
ich wäre jetzt der Sache auch nicht
prinzipiell abgeneigt, wenn ich den
großen Vorteil mal bei irgendeinem Projekt
sehen würde.
Zumal ich es nicht auf 8, das ist das
Ding, richtig Chat. Wenn ich jetzt
irgendwie eine Seite bauen würde,
die ich auf 8 Milliarden User skalieren
muss, das ist was anderes.
Dann würde ich mir keinen
Hetzner
V-Server hinstellen.
Hetzner Cloud-VM.
Und mein ASP.NET Core Backend drauf machen
mit drei APN-Punkten
oder einem GraphQL-Endpunkt und fertig.
Nee, dann würde ich mir was anderes
überlegen, aber solange
das nicht so ist.
Wobei man sagen muss, Authentication
muss man ja auch nicht selber machen,
selbst wenn man
eine Web, also ein eigenes Backend laufen
lässt. Ich würde nie Authentifizierung
selbst implementieren. Ja, es gibt
zig Libraries, die einfach fix und fertig
dir ermöglichen, dass du die üblichen
Verdächtigen machen kannst, wie
GitHub
oder Google
oder was auch immer als Authentifizierung.
Oder es gibt auch komplett
fertige Services dafür.
Und das dann in ASP.NET
als Authentification
Provider reinzuhauen, ist tatsächlich
nicht sonderlich schwierig.
Habe ich sogar
letztens von Patrick was
gebastelt in der Richtung mit Azure,
Azure AD Authentifizierung. Also
gehen tut das. Ist auch nicht sonderlich schwierig,
wenn man weiß, wie es geht.
Oder man nimmt eine Linux-VM
und haut sich seinen fünf Zeilen Backend drauf
und gut ist.
Mit einem GraphQL Endpunkt.
Fertig.
The most important thing
is the database.
Firebase uses Firestore,
which is a document database
similar to MongoDB,
which can get the job done for most apps,
but does have some limitations
that can be kind of annoying at times.
A traditional SQL database
is probably the safest bet
for most people, but they're generally
harder to work with.
Although there are some services out there
like PlanetScale and CockroachDB
that have made things a lot easier in recent years.
Vielleicht hat er immer noch den besten Namen, Alter.
...when used with an ORM like Prisma.
In addition, you might consider other
NoSQL databases like Redis and Cassandra,
which can actually be used as a primary app database.
Now, in addition to the backend,
there are a lot of other smaller tools in the stack.
When it comes to testing,
but not anyone else,
there is a simple question in question...
... what we usually do is
to test something.
In fact, I won't test anything at all.
And my preferred way to do that
is with Cypress, which is basically
an all-in-one path.
And just look at
how easy it can be to do
something like a high-performance
auto-complete search
in Postgres.
You can do it out of the box
with no other tool.
Datenbank machen.
Ja, und SQLite ist eh das Beste für
Build-In-Geschichten. Ich glaube,
90% meiner Anwendungen sind einfach nur SQLite.
Alter, das Video ist auch nur gemacht,
um möglichst viele Technologien
droppen zu können, oder?
Was brauchst du in SQLite für Datentypen,
die nicht drin sind? Ich verwende ja
SQLite nicht direkt mit Raw-Queries,
ich verwende einfach das
Entity-Framework-Core-Modul
und das hat mir bisher
eigentlich so gut alles, was es gibt,
serialisiert, passend in die
SQLite-Datenbank rein.
Siehst du? Leute,
hier haben wir wieder den Punkt.
Eigener Backend mit Postgres
autocomplete
schnell wie Sau
und easy zu implementieren.
Du kannst mit Postgres relativ
easy große Text,
ähm, große Anzahl an
Text indizieren für Volltext-Suche
oder du machst das,
was wir in einem der letzten Streams
schon ein bisschen her, gemacht haben,
und das ist das, was wir in einem der letzten Streams schon ein bisschen hergemacht haben,
du machst ein
Postgres-Tree-Cram-Index,
heißt das, glaube ich,
wo er immer so Dreier-Wörter-Paare indiziert,
da kannst du dann quasi autocomplete
machen, super schnell, auch bei,
also auch
über Wortgrenzen hinweg, also du fängst
dann an zu tippen, ja, zum Beispiel,
was weiß ich, in einem Feld tippst du
A und dann fängt er dir schon an, die Sachen
vorzuschlagen. Und das geht
sauschnell, Leute, wir hatten irgendwie
8-9 Millisekunden-Queries und wir haben die
Datenbank voll gepumpt, Alter.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was das für,
der Stream ist schon ein halbes Jahr her oder so.
Wir haben die Datenbank voll gepumpt, Alter, mit
Milliarden Einträge und das ging schnell wie
Sau.
Okay, wenn ich irgendwann mal eine Seite
machen würde mit Payment, dann,
ja, vielleicht, ja.
Wegen deinem Stream habe ich auch sowas gebaut,
mit Postgres, siehst du, scheint ja
nicht so bei mir funktioniert zu haben.
Was soll ich für ein Video, nee, da kann ich kein Video
zu machen. Hier, wir haben doch mal im Stream
Archive, nicht Archive Org,
Archive, wo ist hier, wo bloß Archive?
Da haben wir doch hier Postgres.
Postgres.
Ja. Im zweiten
Stream haben wir das dann besonders optimiert.
Oh, EGIT,
SQL, ist der Stream,
abgekackt zwischendurch, kann das sein?
Das Colorscheme ist
Pog. Ist das jetzt das gleiche
oder nicht? Ah, hier.
Ah, hier, guck, da ist das, das ist doch
die, der ist doch der Input.
Seht ihr, wie schnell das geht?
Guck mal, guck mal, wie schnell das Auto completed, Alter.
Guckt euch die Datenbank, wir haben 5 Millisekunden
Datenbank-Querys, 1 Millisekunde
und die Datenbank haben wir voll gehauen mit
Zeug. Also, da kannst du nichts
sagen, Postgres ist schon wirklich next, next
level shit. Da ist ja alles
möglich eingebaut. Jason,
Handling,
Indizierung, Volltext-Suche,
Teil-Wort-Suche,
alles.
Es kommt drauf an. Ne, in der Regel würde ich sagen,
ist MySQL schneller als Postgres.
Ob
MariaDB, keine Ahnung. Aber im Prinzip
würde ich sagen, ist
MySQL ein Tick schneller. Das ist ja auch so
das Aushängeschild von MySQL, ist ja quasi
mit, ähm,
mit NoSQL kann man es jetzt nicht
vergleichen, das sind unterschiedliche Anwendungsgebiete.
Ähm, in der Regel würde ich sagen, ist
MySQL ein Tick schneller.
Aber Feature-mäßig, finde ich, steckt
Postgres so ziemlich alles in die Tasche, was es
gibt. Und auch
SQLite ist erstaunlich schnell.
SQLite ist, würde ich sagen, in der
Regel sogar die schnellste Datenbank, die du
haben kannst, also SQL-Style.
Aber, wo halt SQLite
komplett in die Knie geht, ist,
wenn du, ähm,
mehrere
Zugriffe drauf hast, ja. Also, wenn du zum Beispiel
irgendwie
eine Webseite hast,
die
irgendwelche
Requests bekommt und dann Sachen
in die States, in die Datenbank schreiben will,
und wenn das parallel passieren soll,
dann kannst du SQLite knicken.
SQLite selber ist aber sehr, sehr
zackig, ja. Du kannst
davon ausgehen, Postgres kann so ziemlich
alles, was MySQL auch
kann. Sag ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht genau.
Ähm,
aber
Postgres kann, wie gesagt,
das ist ja, also Transactions ist ja Standardzeug.
Du kannst damit so viel
mehr machen von, wie gesagt, Vollintex,
du hast komplett integriertes JSON-Handling,
alles mögliche. Also,
ja, genau. Also, ne, wenn
du wirklich einen SQL-Server
brauchst, ist mit SQLite natürlich
äh, für den Arsch.
Was hältst du von Custom Windows? Von was?
Also, Postgres war
zumindest früher so, ist was
SQL,
was Standards angeht, beziehungsweise
die Implementierung, wie umfang-, also
wie vollumfänglich sind SQL-Sachen
implementiert, war Postgres eigentlich
immer vor MySQL. Dafür hat MySQL gesagt,
aber wir sind in manchen Bereichen
schneller.
Nein, das kenn ich nicht.
Niii, Niochali, QQ, drei Monate,
danke für den massive Sub.
In meiner Ausbildung? Naja, ich hab ja,
wie gesagt, 2007 auf Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration gelernt. Ja, wir hatten auch,
ähm, was war das, LF2?
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr, was Programmieren und Datenbanken
war. Das war nicht sonderlich
sinnvoll.
Für meine normalen Sachen benutze ich kein Kubernetes.
Ne, wozu?
Wozu, wozu sollte
ich irgendwie eine Webseite mit fünf Usern
oder
irgendeine To-Do-Web-App oder
äh, eine Web-App für meinen Fernseh-EPG?
Warum sollte das, oder war das
in der Welt, die Kubernetes laufen?
Außer, weil's geht vielleicht, ja.
Oracle ist
vor allem Beste, wenn's ums Geld geht, ja.
Ja, stimmt, es ist nicht agil, wenn's nicht im Kubernetes
Cluster läuft. Okay, Leute. Ja, da
bin ich halt nicht agil, das ist auch okay.
Ich, ich find die, ich find die Aussprache
ja immer geil. Ich sag immer Kubernetes,
das ist ja eigentlich falsch, die coolen Leute sagen ja
Kubernetes. Ich kann das gleich aufführen.
K-C-мос Kubernetes?
Oder so?
K-K-Kubanetes?
Kubernetes?
Ist wahrscheinlich immer wie eine Krankheit, immer.
Ich,
Kutberneetes, ja.
Kubernetes, ja.
Ach, das ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Kubernetes.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich sag Kubernetes.
Das, das,
Kann man das aufmachen? Ja.
Scaled Agile Big Picture.
Also Dev redet mit End-User ist immer so ein Ding.
Ich möchte nicht mit End-Usern reden.
End-User sind immer hochgradig Pains-Champ.
Redet jemand von euch gerne mit End-Usern?
Noch nicht mal die Hotlines, die bezahlt werden mit End-Usern zu reden,
die reden wirklich gerne mit End-Usern.
Niemand redet gerne mit End-Usern.
Ja.
End-User sind Pains-Champ.
Leider sind End-User erforderlich dafür, dass wir einen Job haben.
Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass ich mich mit denen auseinandersetzen muss.
Magst du Kundenkontakt?
Hört sich das an, als mag ich Kundenkontakt, ja?
Kein Kundenkontakt ist der beste Kundenkontakt.
Ja, ich kann mir das schon vorstellen, dass das auch nicht alles Kacke ist.
Außer C++.
Da ist alles Kacke.
Boah, das ist eine Philosophie-Frage.
Ehrlich gesagt, für mich ist das nicht so.
Für mich sind das Mitarbeiter, weil du musst zusammen mit denen Probleme lösen.
Ich weiß, aus BWL- und Manager-Sicht wird da immer gern von Kunden gesprochen, aber das ist Blödsinn.
Du setzt dich nicht mit einem Kunde zusammen und fragst ihn,
sag mal, wann läuft denn euer Deploy-Skript?
Das ist Schwachsinn.
Du arbeitest mit den Leuten in der IT-Abteilung zusammen.
Da wird zwar gerne gesagt, das sind unsere Kunden,
aber das ist aus praktischen Gesichtspunkten eigentlich Schwachsinn.
Das sind Mitarbeiter.
Ja, was weiß ich, wenn...
Stell dir vor, du bist Linux-Admin.
Und du musst mit einem von der E irgendwie ihre Deployment-Skripte angucken,
weil das fehlschlägt, weil irgendwie Ordnerberechtigungen falsch sind, sonst was.
Ja, da kannst du aus BWL-Sicht sagen, ja, das ist mein Kunde, aber nee, ist es nicht.
Du arbeitest mit dem zusammen, ihr analysiert das und guckt, dass am Endeffekt der Kram deployed werden kann.
Also, das ist eher so eine philosophische Sache, wie man das jetzt nennt.
Unterm Strich ändert es nicht viel.
Ja, das ist bei uns auch so.
Da wird oftmals gerne...
So nach dem Motto, ha, du hast dir den Auftrag nicht richtig aufgemacht,
deswegen können wir das jetzt nicht bearbeiten.
Und da fehlt die Anforderung, wie ist das denn hier und so und da.
In Wirklichkeit sind das Probleme, die teilweise in einer Viertelstunde behoben werden,
wenn sich mal die zwei richtigen Leute zusammensetzen.
Aber es dauert dann drei Monate,
bis es vielleicht mal irgendwann dazu kommt,
dass die richtigen Leute sich zusammensetzen.
Wenn überhaupt.
Meistens sind es dann nicht die richtigen Leute und dann klappt es nicht.
Und dann ist es so, dass man sich nicht mehr so gut befindet.
Und man hat halt viele unfähige Leute an Positionen,
wo sie eigentlich was anderes machen müssten, als sie machen.
Ja, zum Beispiel Organisatoren, die nicht organisieren oder sowas.
Oder Entwickler, die nicht programmieren können.
Oder Admins, die keine Ahnung haben, wie man System D Sachen disabled.
Oder es gibt überall so viele unfähige Leute.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Leute, wisst ihr, was wir nachher machen?
Wir basteln nachher.
Ja, ein bisschen Python Zeug im Stream habe ich mir überlegt.
Ich muss meine Python Skills absteppen und wir basteln irgendwas.
Ich weiß noch nicht genau, was.
Ja, wir machen Python Skills nachher.
Wann circa?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wahrscheinlich heute Nachmittag.
Es sei denn, ich werde gleich abgelenkt von MMO Sucht oder so.
Nicht mit TensorFlow.
Ich muss mal wieder aufhören.
Ich muss mal aufrechen, wie das funktioniert.
Da fange ich jetzt bestimmt nicht mit TensorFlow an.
Ich habe mir schon überlegt.
Also ich würde gerne mit meinem Zabbix ordentlich checken, meine Downloadrate auch nachts und so.
Und aktuell mache ich das so.
Ich habe einfach einen Weget auf eine 200 MB Testdatei und gucke, wie lange es gedauert hat und teile das dann durch 200 MB.
Und dann weiß ich ungefähr.
Aber das ist nicht wirklich gut.
Das ist nicht wirklich gut, die Messung.
Ja, wir könnten ein kleines Python Skript machen, was Download Messung macht.
So irgendwie dreimal samplen.
Drei Sekunden oder so.
Und dann noch ein bisschen Python basteln, weil ich habe zwar prinzipiell schon Ahnung.
Ich kann das lesen.
Ich habe das auch schon öfters mal gemacht.
Aber ich bin da kein großer, großer Python Experte.
Aber ich dachte mir jetzt so.
Es ist schon eine gute Gelegenheit, sich das mal ein bisschen anzugucken, weil ich habe in letzter Zeit öfters Probleme gehabt.
Da waren Bash Skripte zu kompliziert oder zu painstamp dafür, weil es zu lang ist.
Also Bash ist wunderbar.
Es ist wunderbar, wenn sich das so in zehn Zeilen bewegt oder so.
Ich weiß, es gibt Leute, die Bash Skripten sich 800 Zeilen zusammen.
Aber ich finde, Bash ist einfach keine wirklich schöne Sprache.
Bash ist wunderbar, wenn du vielleicht mal eine Schleife brauchst, irgendwie ein paar Krebs hintereinander oder so.
Und dann ist auch gut.
Das ist wunderbar.
Dafür ist Bash oder generell Shell Skripten das Beste, was du machen kannst.
Du kriegst mit nichts so schnell sinnvolle Ergebnisse wie mit einem Shell Skript.
Aber sobald es ein bisschen komplizierter wird, willst du es eigentlich mit Bash nicht machen.
Wusstet ihr, dass ihr in Bash Hashmaps bzw. Dictionaries verwenden könnt?
Das ist aber halt die abartigste Syntax aller Zeiten.
Guckt euch das mal an.
What the fuck?
Also ich meine hier.
Was ist das?
Das will man dann.
Da hört es dann auf.
Das will man da nicht machen.
Ja, das geht.
Das geht jetzt für sich betrachtet noch.
Aber wenn du, also alles ab 20 Zeilen wird in Bash eklig.
Also sobald du mehr brauchst als eine Schleife, vielleicht mal ein If und irgendwie ein paar Krebs hintereinander, ein paar gepipete Bash Befehle, dann wird es eklig.
Wenn du Variablen brauchst, wo State gespeichert wird, wo du dann unten wieder nachguckst.
Es ist eklig.
Also genau, quasi wenn du scrollen musst, ist es zu lang.
Und für solche Sachen würde sich ein bisschen Python Sachen tatsächlich anbieten, wenn ich davon mehr Ahnung hätte.
Da könnte man schlicht und ergreifend schneller Sachen zusammenbasteln.
Wo es sich nicht für lohnt, irgendwie ein .NET Programm zu machen.
Vor allem, ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen, so ein .NET self-contained executable ist immer noch 40 MB oder so, weil das ganze Framework mit dabei ist.
Und die ganze Runtime.
So.
Leute, da gehe ich jetzt auf.
Ich gehe jetzt was zuerst machen.
Dann sehen wir uns, wie gesagt, falls mich nicht die MMO-Sucht packt, sehen wir uns heute Nachmittag wieder.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.